all right party people you know what
time it is all right party people you
know what time it is it says we're live
but only you can tell us for sure we
have to know if you can hear us and if
you can hear us well yes everyone start
talking start saying things talking
words and talking to make sure people
can hear some news new equipment in the
studio today so hopefully it all works
out let's make sure you can hear us we
will know it's 10 15 seconds validate
verify
are we live we just need to make sure
you can hear us in both ears especially
if you're listening on headphones we're
going to kick this stream off so many
versions of not telling us if we're live
finally finally what a strange
live okay okay we're good brendan vella
is our hero tonight all right guys we're
gonna kick this off all right so
um
just a heads up we don't want to be live
for too long tonight we often have a
habit of saying we're not going to be
live for too long then we're live for
far too long so i got some videos to
prep for the morning and uh koi is here
though and i was like well we got koi we
got to do a live stream right now
because he couldn't be in the reaction
with us pizza time he had something much
better to do than being our silly little
video
and also uh there's a couple of things i
really i want to get into right away
that people were noticing especially in
the brazil edit something that paul from
heavy spoilers pointed out to me and we
got a couple of images that we do want
to show you guys uh from it i'm sure
there's a couple of things already but
yeah okay they're saying we sound like a
robot john oh no okay but it's fine
that's that's at least something um
audio kind of bad things have gone awry
uh i do want to say while we're
adjusting uh i know nothing more than
you guys it wasn't there weren't a
series of trailers i watched the same
trailer so anything i say here is not
the opinion of sony sony pictures or any
information that you don't have because
i don't want this clipped out and
they're like you said a thing that i
don't know
yes yes okay so who sounds do do all of
us sound a little bit weird or should we
all
greg and john sound the weirdest right
now okay
these mics are getting old i think uh
okay
we're working on it okay john it's okay
put all this in the hands of john today
just just pressure and stress
that's for you
greg and john sound like stormtrooper
the sugar spice and everything nice mine
is just just that and stress yeah koi is
okay all right all right
that's good because you're on the new
machine which i think is older than this
machine just gotta bear with us as we're
fixing this really quick yep living the
dream living the dream sounds weird all
right only greg and john so koi sounds
great that's perfect just yeah we got
sorry guys go in the stream and just do
this every single time country western
we'll all just rock the mic
just me now just you do it okay john
make a test we're gonna do we're gonna
do live stream test right now come on
john guys vibe you got it buddy no one's
mad at you john no one's gonna you know
we know you're doing it everyone will
tweak a little tweak yep here we go i
want everyone at home right now to give
john a round of applause this is all
gonna be cut out of the stream after
just for you after we have this
completely processed
but yeah it's a gift from us to you
do we sound any better right now it's
not terrible sounds like vader those are
two different ways you sound okay in my
headphones now i sound okay oh no you're
still coy's mic
hello
hello john
is that better
we're a little stereo scoped but we're
listenable on these headphones so on the
great headphones only the elitist only
this nice headphone notch
sort of experience it's better i'm
clapping
greg still sounds weird we got a lot of
conflicting reports all right then you
know what i wanted to share we're gonna
have to improvise yeah and we're gonna
have to work together here and this is
gonna be an awkward intimate stream
today friends we're gonna share a mic
yeah that's how we're gonna do it yeah
all right whoa that's how we stream
today we ain't john campia stereoscope
we're better
toby's dick
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's gonna go well folks try it try that
other mic now all right let's see how
this goes okay guys we're gonna be
listening john's gonna be taking in your
feedback look
coy
as you all know today
let me i'm gonna just just for safety
i'm doing some koi's mike
as you all know today koi hosted the fan
event
where
they debuted the trailer coy is pretty
much the one who introduced the trailer
to the world today where tom holland was
oh that big trailer fan event that you
all heard about he was supposed to be in
the reaction with us
and then 24 hours ago after we still
like part of the sketch was his idea
and i was like all right man i gotta
find a costume i went to four different
stores to find this costume and then we
shot some of it and he told me he can't
make it because he had to host it and of
course i was like screw that come to our
show and he's like not gonna happen
and here we are no i it was actually uh
i was so looking forward to the sketch
and the and the the being here and the
reaction and i told
i told greg like i there's no reason i
i'll be there and then and then um the
reason happened
uh that being said it was absolutely
surreal to have that conflict of my
favorite place to make content being
this space or the thing that i love
doing most in the world besides making
content in this space well like it was a
it was a an abundance of riches uh i had
the honor of
getting it was amazing it was an episode
of the newsroom i got there and then i
had a 17
point uh processes of this is what needs
to be accomplished
this is gonna be you won't be able to
see it because of the lighting
but this is the chaos
[Laughter]
and i'm not gonna i'm not gonna read any
specifics to you guys but here's how
stringent this schedule is
five o'clock to 505 pm a sec three
sentences of work
508 to 5 12 p.m
four sentences
12 to 5 15 pm i'm just like how are you
supposed to manage hosting this with the
weirdest times you got to be obedient to
and i had a mic in my ear like a shield
agent i had a guy cueing me here i had
someone for speed over here and i had a
fan person here all while all of this is
getting set up to be both here and in
mexico city so it was truly the most
stimuli i think a human body could have
in one place and then they added tom
holland so like i've got all of this and
then tom gets there and i get to talk to
tom beforehand because the last thing
you want is to meet someone live in
front of 480 people and another 480
people and the thousands of people and
then the millions of people that watch
it later so uh tom and i talked a bit
and i as you guys may know um i love all
the spider-man's but the tomah's like a
really special spider-man to me and
tonight
he proved
more than any movie yet
that in his answers
that boy spider-man at one point i
quoted ned and i was like oh dude
spider-man and i was like oh i'm
literally like i can't you're just
spider-man and it was so incredible to
be with someone that loves this as much
as we do so authentically it's not a
paycheck it's not i'm uh an actor it's
not i'm an actor playing it's the guy
loves peter parker and spider-man so
much that it radiates he he got
emotional with the trailer and and we
got to share like a moment of yeah
what just happened with the audience
that's like waited for hours that like
is just emoting and cheering and and it
was a one of one
concert experience for nerds it was
literally like what i imagined seeing
your favorite band was at their like
first big show but you're all front row
and i got to i got to share that with
someone who's given us
this spider-man who's as invested as us
and sony man sony cares so much sony i
mean that's why it's down to the three
minutes like
that wouldn't happen if sony was like
put out the trailer they're like okay i
want you to accomplish this many
sentences you've got roughly this
cadence we're gonna and they're so the
team that's on it so invested and they
gave so many craps about my opinion like
they'd ask me as a comic book fan like
if we do this and this and if this
question's okay for this and how to
shape this and i honestly i stayed uh
two more shows i basically stayed for
fun and experienced the trailer with
other audiences and then i asked trivia
questions gave up posters and because i
was so in love with the vibe and that
was sony so i i really want to if sony's
watching this hello thank you for
carrying sony loves our livestream
sony's here hi hi mr sony uh and tom
holland dude um you are more than the
real deal i didn't do a show with tom
holland today i introduced tom holland's
spider-man but i was with spider-man
like it was it was surreal so uh yeah
how does my mic sound now after
after coy's little stupid rant about
meeting tom hall and hosting
one of the biggest live events in the
world yeah
selfish
yours sounds pretty good mine sounds
good now yeah i want to say i'm honored
that after boy has i'm running you
through coy's uh interface i want to say
that after koi having the experience of
a lifetime
because he told me on saturday that the
only way he would ever skip doing the
reaction with us is if he randomly got
offered to host the event then he got
offered to host the event i was like
well you did give me a heads up
and uh
and then but i'm his honor that he
texted me a little bit after it was done
and he's like you want to meet up i was
like you still want to meet up with us
after you just did that
and then i was like oh social media yeah
i literally was so like okay step one
tom holland step two greg and john step
three rest oh no i have to advertise the
thing i just did because social media it
was so surreal uh because i was like i'm
about to get here yeah i was walking out
to my car going like i'm talking about
i'm mad
i'm so i'm so proud of you i know this
is really what koi wants to be doing and
the fact that you are here like we get
to have such a great uh we have a really
well performing video right now which
i'm very happy about and then i mean i
talked quite extensively this morning
like this is exactly what he's been
wanting to do and i like this is
this is the we we each have our like a
lot of us do the online [ __ ] but we all
have our career paths that we really
want to go down yeah this is way more
along the lines of where coy actually
wants to go so i was like [ __ ] yeah man
that's amazing and i'm not at all
jealous
i saw some people saying that in the
chat and i just want to say there's no
version like i've honestly i don't feel
like i've never
i was more than happy to sit here and
watch it and struggle to make a sketch
that you suggested we do
where i spent eighty dollars on a
costume where i would cut the head off
guys stream
labs the costumes cost that i caused
um but guys look we got to start talking
about some spider-man [ __ ] while we're
here guys
we gotta start we gotta start talking
about some [ __ ] okay uh do we have any
super chats right now by the way i wanna
i i know we got a lot of crap last time
for taking like 35 minutes to get to the
super chat
so let's start there and then we'll go
back to the chat you know yeah start
start streamlabs oh everyone man
youtube we ended up taking we we ended
up spending like 30
like 35 minutes last time and it was
like wow we took way too long to get it
it's okay the chat can check me but i
think i finally got this all right
i think it all sounds fine yeah
so really quick though before i mean
someone might point this out in the
super chat so that's why i didn't want
to uh say it right now but if they
haven't pointed it out then we're gonna
we want to talk about the trailer edit
mistakes
uh from like brazil
and the one that tom holland had we were
you saw with tom holland where he acted
like he couldn't see the mistake
statement i was joking yeah i was like
did you ask tom did you ask tom if uh
think did you ask tom if he uh if toby
and andrew were in it i i was obviously
i walked in and i was like sony give us
a moment excuse me and then i cornered
him and he was like mate i'm getting
appropriately dressed and i was like you
sir you wait and put on that handsome
suit i'ma talk about no i did not
because i value my freedom of not being
in movie prison
john group pull this up now all right
which which one's first super chat sure
let's go with that whichever one
we just got to get this going absolutely
since we got more [ __ ] to do you got
this buddy here let me move i cannot see
past that monolith
yes
awesome all right guys shouts out to
everybody voting in the poll most 73
percent of you are about that
uh three percent last time i checked
were like nah nah bro oh yeah okay i'm
seeing some stuff in here about the
brazilian trailer yeah yeah okay i think
because
that's what goes wrong whenever we wait
forever to get to the super jets
yeah i'm gonna make this one and we're
gonna show the we we're gonna go through
the footage too of that absolutely
absolutely okay
here we go
we're going
i just so deeply miss the chat that's
great good people all right kill that
title overlay i'm gonna have to clean
this all up later but it's good all
right so we got cam k here cam k
seriously you've got to check out the
lizard brazil cut going around my man's
face gets hammered by something
invisible perhaps edit out hmm thank you
cam k pointed out john you got that
footage drop it through that beautiful
bean footage all right we're gonna show
the footage here of the lizard and you
guys tell me if you think that spider
that a certain spider-man was edited out
or not
all right let's go frame by frame here
oh yeah all right so here we go pay
attention to lizard pay attention to
lizard watch lizards motion watch losers
motion here i'm going to move this yeah
watch loser's motion look at his face
jerk
it looks like something is punching him
something is swinging and hitting him in
that moment it's a weird jerk isn't it i
played it play it regularly john all
right pull it back to the beginning
watch his
yeah
face
doesn't look like something's just
hitting there's nothing landing on his
face and the way he's turning is clearly
like someone's landing a blow on it i
mean the only thing i think you could
argue is like maybe they're trying to
play it like it's the wind from this
right hook that sandman's throwing but
it it looks too sharp it looks like he's
getting caught directly perpendicular by
some you know all right go back to us
all right copy that hey look it's us i
think he sneezed yeah
that's right did tom holland answer this
for you at the fan live event
the tom's they give you a list of
appropriate tom holland responses like i
am the tom holland of this yeah i
totally think now they cut something out
of there thank you cam k for finally
getting us to that moon arc don't worry
john i could read some in the better
viewpoint uh decoy getting the inside
info at the event need to know that's a
great question koi did you get any
inside info that you could share looks
like he sneezed
um i got uh some some info about uh
basically some i got some cool for movie
nerd stuff like what he's doing for the
tour and i got some info about like
what's the next steps of this thing it's
all very like the the minutia of big
film uh i think the biggest thing that
uh
inside info i got was seeing it
before everyone and literally
experiencing the full weight of being in
a room with kevin feige he wasn't there
but i felt the pressure of like i was
walked into a trade into a into a
theater that literally i had to go by a
round of security to get to the hallway
to get to this theater that had security
around it and then while i was in that
theater i was sat with sony execs while
someone watched us watch it so i was
literally like hello i'm breaking into
alcatraz to watch this trailer but i'm
being escorted so it was uh inside stuff
was like i did get to see it a little
early so i could do my job uh obviously
i was i was interviewing about the
trailer so i needed some time to
formulate but only like a few minutes
before everyone else because it was
really cool that they wanted to make
sure the whole world got the trailer at
the exact same moment it was very
important to them to the point where we
talked about the minute to minute thing
they knew the trailer was going live at
a certain minute so i set a phone alarm
in my pocket to go off one minute before
as a minute warning for me to wrap up
whatever to pitch to the trailer um so
the most inside stuff i got was being a
part of the sony experience of setting
this up so it went off without a hitch
uh and my favorite thing and you're
gonna hate this answer and i gave a long
answer because it's a stream lab and i
respect you but the real answer is if i
knew
you wouldn't
uh because i just i can't um i i love
that this trailer didn't give us
anything um that would ruin my
experience later and so many trailers do
so i got a lot out of how this trailer
did so i i want to know very little i
think
i think we already got some photos that
went online recently we don't need it in
the trailer let's just keep it at that
john let's move on buddy all righty
looks like a sneeze
drew makowsky thank you so much for the
super chat drew he said been waiting for
what you have to say well here we are
saying [ __ ] drew thank you buddy jason
diaz john's still in the spidey suit you
know gotta go hard when it's the way i
don't get to wear it often so i like to
make the most of it i mean john's been
the spidey super [ __ ] hours man
those are uncomfortable as [ __ ] they are
yeah and as many times i've worn this i
think it's stretched out to accommodate
like it's it's found a way to be
ill-fitting on me but that finally feels
like it's given up and it's just going
okay fine i'm not gonna make this
painful yes
so i feel like i need some meiosis yeah
i got to take this advantage while it
doesn't feel agonizing
but uh i appreciate that you appreciate
it is male montoya coy really happy for
you man greetings thanks so much i'm
happy coy's show here after that's great
and then uh let's keep moving up
squidward tortonelli some eight-year-old
kids stream the whole stream the whole
event
i i haven't seen find him yeah i was
like i haven't seen me i found out i'm
not even kidding they were here for this
i found out about an hour ago two hours
after the event that my face was on the
screen like my brain was so focused on
making sure the the people were happy
and making sure i was engaged in the
conversation with tom i never noticed
that i was being projected onto the
theater screen of course i was wearing a
movie theater so i saw a video and i was
like guys did you know and they're like
yeah you were at a movie theater so uh i
would like this eight-year-old's footage
i think we would all like being here
jar of snokes first batman superman
reference in eternals now commissioner
gordon spider-man
one word describes his courage it's true
you know i honestly i had to do a split
second of a workaround because when i
saw jk simmons because of the type of it
was like a pompadour hat yeah that he
was wearing yeah i immediately thought
of commissioner gordon oh and then my
mind had to go no wait he's jay james
he's not gordon
so i got a little bit like oh wait a
minute i also have to say i was at a
party with jk simmons two nights ago and
we were talking about the experience of
playing jay joner jameson and like
adjusting to the new world of spider-man
like the classic sam raimi flavor versus
this flavor and he was describing the
new jonah and then i saw this picture i
saw this flash and i was like oh it's
literally like he's got a different vibe
all together like this yeah oh okay so
it was really interesting like he is so
conscious of the character that through
his description this is that like this
feels like a different jonah same actor
yeah that makes sense and that's in a
frame that's that's acting and and great
wardrobe but like that's a different
joke it's a different jonah especially
he saw that jonah from the raven ones
already saw sandman fighting [ __ ] yeah
that's right much a bunch of uh amongst
the construction site wouldn't you know
it yeah now
it's back i have a well i i won't
pollute anything in case anybody else
brings it up yeah yeah yeah someone will
believe it ismail montoya thank you is
male 1
well no way home be the greatest mcu
movie of all time we'll just have to
wait and see
i'm wondering if the numbers of the
performance could rival that of avengers
infinity war though that's my big ques
if the movie is good it it
don't expect it to be their greatest
movie but i do expect it to be one of
their most like uh
grippingly significant i'll say like one
thing that um
i'm very curious about when it comes to
no way home
is this whole thing about toby mcguire
and andrew garfield because of the
photos that came out you know some
people still doubt those photos yeah so
it's like some people are going to show
up going i want to see if andrew and
toby are in it
or absolutely positive marketing or i
want to get to confirm that they're in
it you know so yeah like it's it's smart
what they have going if anything that
those leaks seem like they're doing well
no matter what i've never i honestly
i've been to a lot of comic cons i was
in hall h and i'm not comparing so
please don't like saying this has been
this i was in hall h for the loki moment
where tom hiddleston came out for loki
this felt like that and it was like a
100th of the people like you can only
squeeze you know 500 people in a theater
somehow that room felt like hall h with
tom hiddleston so like it was insane did
anybody come up to you and say why
wasn't toby or andrew here you know the
thing about sneezing
is an affection
all right let's move on time let's move
on then jordan garza
um you all sounded like bane also first
time doing a super chat just wanted to
say this guys
just wanted to say huge fan been
watching ever since i was probably too
young
thank you jordan garza that means a lot
guys i want to go to something really
quick that i haven't heard many people
talking about heavy spoilers paul
pointed this out to me
um oh wait a minute oh oh victoria the
one who suggested the schedule
yes it was you it was her she suggested
it victoria i gotta say that i looked
for your tweet for about yeah i don't
know an hour and then realized it was on
instagram all along and then i went back
and found it was it was a journey
because we wanted to make sure you knew
how much we appreciated uh that that
whole thing so thank you because we were
um uh yeah koi told me like we should do
the spider-man point thing and i'm like
i don't know what the joke sketch
how are we gonna lead into this exactly
i don't know like we're just pointing in
here like we do all the different you
were like you said i'm toby you're
totally like i don't get this sketch
i didn't understand what you were
pitching me i posited that each of us do
a different spider-man and then we like
end up pointing and it makes sense up
here at one in the morning but i didn't
words it good yeah and uh victoria it
was you you incepted this got something
someone to think we went that out very
last minute
great sketch and then risk runner um
love you real rejects been a fan since i
was 14 love the sketch koi how are you
feeling right now greg and john how
excited are you guys i'm more excited
for koi right now yeah anything else
biggest day of all of us
i honestly uh i'm only live because of
you [ __ ] i i came over and i was like
actually you wake up both you napping
comfortably enjoying your rest both
sketchy snapping face on keyboard yeah
i'm gonna shake you up we're going live
i set all this up it's not even john who
entirely spent the last hour and a half
setting this up it's it's it's all me
is that we're at the top of this one i
know we got more that we when we refresh
it we're almost at the top we'll yeah
have you seen i feel good well i want to
use gary catlow to show this other image
um have you seen the brazilian trailer
lizard gets hit by an invisible person
toby and andrew confirmed we did i mean
that's not a confirm but we didn't show
that earlier in this stream obviously
but john can you put this other image
that paul from heavyspoiler sent me
let's go full screen on this let's let
the let's let the frame take up the
entire thing yes
how are you doing koi i was just making
sure that wasn't my team saying i said
something so paul from heavy spoilers
pointed this out to me i'm not sure
which trailer this is from it might be
from the regular trailer tell me when
i'm getting close to making this full
screen because from here we need to go
to view
oh yeah right there never mind
it's hard to see all right so
put your air hover the arrow go to the
left go to the left
more that right there next to ned put
your arrow there that is andrew
garfield's arm from the poles right
there in the trailer am i am i
highlighting the right thing can you see
it john you see the hand grip
that's a hand gripping it and they
didn't properly cg and i have oh my
goodness or did they leave that for us
okay so
to me that looks like it could be some
sort of artifact from a breakage it
could be wreckage that is being thrown
through the air it could be any number
of things causing something to look like
it's in motion because this is a motion
shot this could be anything or
especially a sneeze or uh or koi's just
saying [ __ ] and that's definitely
i feel like maybe it could be sneezing
some more guys
what do you guys think what do you guys
think that is do you think that's an arm
that they did not successfully cgi out i
am john what do you think uh
i mean because there's only ned and mj i
feel like it could easily be tom holland
if they wanted to but also just why
would they cgi uh tom holland in this
shot
well that's a great ques i i don't know
it's it's it's
the 4k version to know i mean if that's
just a glaring if it's just really a
dangling arm then that's a mistake and
it must be andrew or any of them because
i don't know if he's holding on to a
scaffolding or a bar or a rail i have to
imagine the rest of them have an
opportunity to do that too
all right well no no
where do you guys i'm on tv andrew all
right no it's not a leaked photo that's
from the trailer
yeah
they want them in the trailer maybe we
can make some mistakes
let's just have it in there that's the
other thing is i don't know that i i
don't want to be the editor who people
then think screwed up but at the same
time i think that's fun let's go to our
uh we got some in the stream labs right
now too absolutely at some point we're
gonna cut off this stuff like we're at
some point we appreciate everyone who's
here we do have some videos to prep got
the stream labs loading thank you guys
for joining in the la the latest poll 3
800 of you 62 most excited for green
goblin followed by electro than lizard
then only seven percent of people care
about my dude's sand man big i think
sandman is the best best part of
spider-man iii
hit man how's the reason we're friends
coy there's a reason we're friends going
correct correct all right we're gonna go
through these quickly all right normally
we spend way too long on each one and so
we make that up today by going through
it fast
first we appreciate the support very
much so we do jg2916 thank you for the
moment of silence that is very sweet of
you and anthony perchak per cap
why don't you read that buddy currently
it worked but i had to tune in to hear
you guys talk about the trailer i'm
happy they didn't show toby and andrew
save it for the movie i am okay with
that agree we've been saying that 215
have said on record we don't whether or
not they're in it we don't want to see
it and this is the trailer
it's like i feel like this chat just
only wants to talk about that one shot
with lizard possibly being punched
pretty excited about the punch pretty
excited about this
moment in
brazilian punch lizard in a brazilian
trailer roman unchained what's up greg
and john and coy can finally catch a
live stream koi bravo on hosting the
trailer premiere thank you sony shocked
me they held back on you know who while
showing what the story might be hoping
to see some of you at comic-con next
week cheers
i hear one of us is going to comic-con
next week i have three panels uh i don't
know who's attending them i know who i'm
moderating them for but i don't know
anyone else going to comic-con i'm glad
you're going it seems i want to see
people there i've got three panels uh
two friday one saturday so i'll be there
um san diego thanksgiving weekend i'm
sure koi has made
hundreds of thousands of dollars in the
last two weeks hundreds
guys do you even understand how well the
internet pays
do you even understand koi is making so
much so much bank i'm just drowning in
spider suits the craziest part about the
fan event is when tom holland whipped
out a fat wad of cash
yeah
it was like it was a weird moment but it
was like he yelled here's your damn
pictures of spider-man and i was like no
those are benjamins and he's like take
him and he threw him out
all right man and they're gonna no way
sony keeps that because it's a spoiler
and then what does uk have yen yeah
definitely all right let's move on here
thank you roman unchained willie plays
who is the best spider-man love interest
mary jane gwen stacy or felicia hardy i
personally love felicia hardy
um
coy look who i answered this one the
answer is of course quinn stacy without
gwen stacy you don't get marry jane
without quinn stacy you don't get the
maturation of barry jane who is the
person who loves both peter parker and
spider-man which is the importance of
that character because felicia in my
opinion and the comics opinion only
loves spider-man she's disgusted by
peter parker in canon whereas gwen stacy
never really got to
know that side of her so beautifully
mary jane is the character that gets
both sides and gets to understand which
is why the one more day storyline so
tricky that being said i don't believe
mary jane in the story would have
developed enough of a maturity as she
was a party girl due to all of her
trauma and life stuff which is very
understandable the way they navigated
that to have her mature enough through
the death of gwen stacy in taking care
of spider-man so without the inciting
incident of the tragic loss of his first
love his first full love we wouldn't
have the mary jane we have today so i
think mary jane is the one that he
belongs with but i think without gwen
stacy we wouldn't have the mary jane we
need and gwen stacy is probably the best
pairing with all the science the
knowledge all those things plus the love
they had together is just so special
absolutely true
i'm trying to find that green goblin
without a hood moment i want to get i'm
trying to get a photo on my screen
that's gorgeous is that a new iphone uh
no it's just the iphone 12. is that 4k
trailer because that's gorgeous no all
right well something about it's nice
do you have that photo john yeah i got a
bunch oh john's got a photo there for us
all right there it is all right
let's get that going let's do something
else john uh really quick before we show
that um
uh here why don't you guys talk for a
little bit um
no no no you guys don't talk a little
bit screen i wanna it's a way to
brighten the photo
in this program right here
yeah probably
just color yeah let's see if we can
brighten this photo because people are
saying that that might there it is just
go to exposure yeah there we go perfect
all right so we're here so i want to
interrupt the streamlab thing really
quick because i've seen a lot of people
comment about this in this stream some
people are saying that they think that's
hop goblin and not
um willem dafoe's norman osborne now i
don't know how much you guys
want me to say this
but i believe that is willem dafoe due
to things i've heard about what happens
to the mask i'll just keep it at that
that he doesn't have the mask anymore
at some point he catches sight of a
power rangers episode he's just like
what am i doing yes and then he's having
because a lot of people were reporting
on it that he would like adopt the um
goggle similar to doc ox so that seems
very in line with a lot of what we've
already heard about what would happen i
don't want to go too
leak heavy because i know not everyone
who's here is into the leaks and stuff
like that
yeah you got like the altered suit yeah
so but this this looks like the upgraded
version that he eventually uses
because it wouldn't make i think it
would be way too much to suddenly have
hot and the reason why i'm thinking i'm
talking from a storytelling standpoint
too it'd be a little too much to
suddenly have hop goblin coming into
this also from a storytelling standpoint
it would make more sense to have the
green goblin suit be introduced with the
original mask because of the nostalgia
because that's how we saw him and then
modernize him in canon like yeah if i
was if i was making this movie you've
got these characters like elektro who's
been modernized because now he's got a
comic book accurate suit why not also
make a comic book accurate green goblin
from the goblins so i think this is i i
would put money no i wouldn't i'm poor i
would put 95 percent chance
that's willing to fail but it looks like
william the photo in the facial
structure
it looks like willem dafoe i'm gonna go
i'm gonna go i don't think that's hop
goblin i think a lot of people get
really carried away some people already
see a lot of people coming in the stream
they're like king it's getting in the
purple light i'm like guys no everyone
gets way too carried away sometimes
but i think there's somebody somebody
made a comment on our video about that
about when he says like the universes
are coming and i can't stop them and
someone was like what if it's just 3 000
kings yeah he's not toby or andrew he's
just king yeah
no way home because he's stuck with kang
going through timelines by the way if
you guys haven't seen our trailer
reaction it's up on youtube right now we
still don't know if doing a live stream
affects our videos performance
we'll see click over because now you're
gonna find it with no views tomorrow uh
too chilly for a willy did we get an
homage to all things spider-man felt
some into the spider verse in this
awesome trailer let's go
yeah i mean this is a total spider-verse
trailer in so many ways oh yeah all the
villains echo moments yeah and they're
all combining into this crazy universe
like in spider-verse so i i would say so
all right joe let's move on here copy
that try to keep us on top today guys
looks like there are two goblins in this
trailer that's exactly why i was talking
about this
who flies by with the bombs has goggles
and no dafoe mask that would add up to
six films as well as well instead of
five any thoughts on who it could be
congrats quite i mean if there was a hop
goblin i feel like ned would be likely
to turn into one you know what in the
poll right now that's the least popular
option behind james franco no yeah it's
definitely it's definitely uh uh uh
it's definitely norman osborne all right
let's move on here norm's born toe for
grace opie hey guys my theory post
credit scene for no way home spidey
finding villains to send back maybe
running into venom uh to maybe send him
back as the shipping spider logo venom
we want ooh
a fan service venom fix good job tonight
koi peace and love good job tonight koi
i totally think the post credits scene
there's usually two right in a movie for
mcu one that sets up another movie and
then one that sets up a sequel
and i think one that they will set up is
definitely uh toby mcguire i didn't tell
you where uh tom holland and tom hardy
venom crossover another one indicating
towards that is where i think koi
thoughts i think we're gonna get a very
sony universe building post-credit
scenes i think usually it's one mcu one
sony i think we're gonna get potentially
something allowing for venom and
something along to morbius because
morbius is so soon every every universe
represented on screen will get its own
post-credits there's actually seven
postcards was new rock stars in our
stream for a little bit were they in our
stream for a little bit of comments that
were saying
that a couple people point out new rock
stars
did they come that'd be crazy because i
challenged coy to go up against eric i'm
ready eric death battle take them off
let's go i don't even know how we do
that oh what a sophie's choice for us i
guess they're not here anymore were they
they never were people were lying all
right don't do that to uh here's my
challenge all right new york stars what
are you doing he's like a nice guy what
do you
he needs help for his kindness so much
kindness let's move on here all righty
moving on all right hit man hudson the
man who knows how to take advantage like
at streamlands like nobody's business
so here so my theory is that there is a
villain who is responsible for helping
these villains cross over into the mcu
not just a spell responsible for
resurrecting those villains who died
from the dead and that this villain will
be played by bruce campbell
keep moving up here john i'm sure it
goes longer right
also no way home is now the upcoming
project i am i am most excited excited
for besides the wheel of time i hope you
all end up watching the wheel of time
and liking it tremendously but if not
the wheel weaves as the wheel will we
don't know if we have time in fact we
might okay new rockstars wasn't here
other people point out uh so i don't i
don't know if um we will have time to
cover the wheel of time in fact we might
have to be skipping cowboy bebop we were
just we got a pretty busy schedule
did you like the cowboy people premiere
it's really like scott pilgrim meets
holy crap noir and i dug the tone it's a
lot it's a new rock star said agreed
greg somebody agreed from new rocks what
did he agree with me on
i love movies oh probably the william
defoe thing
he's probably agreeing about willing to
foul let's hope so that's into context
right like green goblin
think so can't believe rockstar is going
to reactions man they give you no
fighting chance no funny chance to be
overwhelmed anymore yeah you hear that
rock stars
freaking blind waving new rock stars
bring some of your viewers to this live
stream
tell them to come over absolutely keep
doing the damn opening sketches trying
to get those numbers up
they're doing [ __ ] man
now we're doing great i really
appreciate everyone who like tunes in
for them it's honestly doing like
phenomenal right now i mean i could tell
you what it's actually at in real time
what do you got what do you got in the
last 60 minutes alone we've gotten 38
866 views on it in total we're at 360
000 views that is incredible so i'm
really grateful for that it's amazing
thank you like it's still awesome to get
views like that so thank you so much
all right uh so we're refreshing these
we're refreshing the pages and as soon
as they're refreshed we will be right
back with you
all right i'll just read the real live
chat right now james franco i don't
think they'll bring back for here
because james franco here's a bit of a
problematic
character yeah people people aren't
about that franco life these days
franco's an interesting lad
i've known some people who met james
franco in real life really yeah they've
had nothing but amazing things to say
about james francis about what i would
expect from his reputation
[Music]
we love the james franco oh man okay so
youtube is having us do a brief
verification that it's us streaming nope
we are in fact because he wants us to oh
they want us to so what the [ __ ] i can't
believe this is happening while live
they're having us while we're live
streaming they're like we need to
confirm this
what unusual activity could possibly be
happening right now
we can't marry boston chat we can't we
can't load this because of the fact that
okay that's so weird youtube is actually
having us do this eric voss i hear
you're very nice and i'm impressed with
your knowledge vos is like an insanely
nice guy yeah he seems nice
i tried completely acting like i wasn't
nervous when i first met him
it was like play cool gray you know
don't jump fanboy out too much man
that's pretty cool
probably on the same level that you
would you felt with tom holland yes it
was it was a very interesting bosses our
holland meeting the kid that you think
actually figured out what spider-man is
to all of us was is it's interesting
because i i usually look in an actor's
eyes and i see all of their performances
and i see the person and i really
struggle to look at tom hall and not be
like spider-man
here we go we're back in action all
right here we are
okay i see some new names all right guys
we're gonna try to end this stream by
like 10 30 to be real with you guys
because we've got so much to do oh my
god we got some big super chats in here
refresh this one more time wait is that
dominance no refresh this one more time
did domino send us pizza money it's
pizza time it's pizza time super chat's
catching up you'll get that pizza when
you fix this damn dog so um
real quick i haven't heard much people
talk about this in stream but i want to
get koi's take on this um is that some
people are thinking that dog hawk ends
up working with them
helping them like he's not a full like
the trailers may be misleading you in
the sense of he turns and he wants to
fight peter for some reason but then
eventually he's not actually like a bad
guy from the trailer i will say that the
conversations i'm having with him very
casually in the it seems to be doc
strange's like sanctum though they're
all trapped i think that's doctrine i
think that wall of them being trapped is
in doctor strange's sanctum i think but
uh from that and him being like you're
not peter and the way
doctor octopus landed in spider-man 2 as
ultimately a good guy
i could see that like it tracks like
from a story standpoint it'll make sense
and uh the other thing what was the oh
my god what was the other thing that a
lot of people were actually saying a
bunch of
okay
let's go through the trailer in our
heads really quick okay
something with okay we were talking
about oh doctor strange that final
moment where people were doctor strange
is saying um
uh i can't stop through and they're
coming through the way he's saying it
has all of us thinking he's probably
talking about toby and andrew but why is
he trying to stop them is he actually
trying to help the villains in that
moment oh
or maybe he doesn't know exactly who's
coming through i just can't stop it from
happening i like the dark strange
because they do they do set up that um
dr strange and peter are going to be at
odds in this movie
over their difference of opinion on what
to do with the prisoners from the other
other dimensions and so he was like
fighting against it and then that moment
in the scene is obviously all the
villains have already come into play
that is interesting because you see
sandman you see lizard you see doc ock
you see like goblin and then uh who's
there's one more missing
lizard
little lecturer yeah so you have all
these electro you have you have all them
there they show that in the trailer
before doctor strange says that but he's
fighting against them coming even though
all the villains are there maybe he's
trying to help out the villains in some
way i like that thing yeah a lot
especially with our big what-if theory
with this yes that evil doctrine and he
definitely felt off he felt more off in
the first trailer and i think they
definitely adjusted accordingly for this
one and i think some of those shots
might be our doctor strange right not
right right
all right there was a cloakless doctor's
training if you guys are here can you
hit the like button that tends to help
us out that would be wonderful all right
let's move on to some we got some super
chats to catch up on i'm going to close
this now why i'm not going to close it
then no let's stress out no no no no no
panic about time throughout
oh my god
no no no we're going to end the the
super chats right now we're just going
to go out there
close close them out close close close
them out i mean as much as we could be
here all night and we appreciate
everyone with their generosity but we
also we have to work on some videos that
we have in the schedule to upload for
tomorrow morning and so we want to make
sure we honor that side of our
subscriber base too that wants those
reactions for arcane and witcher and we
got to prep those and it's going to be
another couple hours for us so we like
we got it we don't want to lose too much
sleep right now and there will be a
peggy carter on patreon hooray yay just
uh
hot show hot show you know
well i got a little bit of marvel
well i got a little bit of marvel uh
relevancy here on my side you know
all right we're getting back in with the
last of the streams and the and the
super chats also
thanks to everybody engaging gotting on
the polls i also want to give sony some
more street cred uh the person my
contact over at sony and i were talking
about comic books and he immediately
started talking about saga and i was
like
so the dude that helps these movies have
the comic book pr is a saga fan so
street cred for days hell yeah man go up
a little bit more johnny
uh i feel like we're not there yet no no
no uh go down now
uh
nah john sounds like doing main
impression we did read that one oh you
went too far but
we definitely did that streamed the
whole event okay glad you also
definitely did that all right
john still sounds like i'm doing a main
impression all right
let's discover that yeah
all right
and we're back i'm sorry jordan garza in
case john still sounds like he's doing a
bane impression of course just in life
oh gosh
i've it's like sean conner well
actually i hear that you cover it up
like this it gets muffled
it's hard
it's hard
like you you can't get into the mic that
way
anyway what the [ __ ] is going on
you can't do a baiting impression
without everyone jumping on you that's
true
let me do my bad baiting
let's all suffer together
john why don't you read ready comment
man red comment man as as christopher
walken hey i've been here
from your early days keep up the good
work
and i'm happy
they kept toby and andrew off the
trailer keep your
money shot
in the movie
that's solid i've never heard you're
walking this is just one of the best
just make sure when you see toby maguire
in there that you check his dick yeah
make sure it's real
make sure it's real i want to agree with
red comet because whether or not they're
in the movie i would never want to like
what a waste and and this like we were
saying advertises both ways yes it's
it's no matter what you want to know if
they're in the movie and you can never
experience that moment for the first
time again so don't waste it yeah that's
why i've never lost my virginity yeah i
can never get to it first time you can
never do it again it won't top that
first time that's what i've heard about
sex
talk about that one gets better than the
first time he just
ellie 9
11 000. check brazilian twitter trailer
we did we talked about we scrubbed it
denocity mate love you guys
i finally was able to catch up on your
livestream
yeah you know no one's really talking
about electro man the silver age
spider-man
face mask that exactly mirrors the comic
book for just a little frame that like
that suit is incredible upgrade the way
jamie fox sounds has me excited jamie
foxx is one of the great actors of our
time if anyone deserves a second chance
like dude's an oscar winner and he's got
the versatility of so many great films
let him be elected again like stealth
horrible bosses horrible bosses too
bubble bosses too oh [ __ ] jones
[ __ ] dude
you know what i'm gonna say i guarantee
you there's at least in a movie of
crowded scene stealing moments i
guarantee you two
jamie foxx scene stealing moments i
guarantee we're gonna be talking about
jamie foxx after this a lot well i think
elektra what makes the character great
he's a tortured soul he's one of those
characters who's literally been cursed
with this
it's a power set he did not ask for
which i think amazing spider-man
did not successfully capture i mean
spider-man 2 but really he is a very
tortured soul dealt a very unfortunate
hand in life yeah and learning how to
control that and also finding a group
like actually in spectacular spider-man
the the series i was one of my favorite
things about the electro was watching
how he felt accepted by people like dr
octopus who you know like obviously had
some hidden agendas with him but he felt
like he was at least understood
and and i think that's a little bit more
characterization we need to kind of give
to a lecturer to really make him click
especially if spider-man's conflicted by
killing everyone yeah
which i think that's the biggest twist
of the trailer
like the fact that there's a line of
dialogue about like they all died at
your hand they all died fighting you
like this is a very different story why
is he saying that though because that's
not true
yeah same man didn't die sandman didn't
die
lizard didn't die at his hand did he i
don't remember that movie honestly
you know what you're right only a doctor
sacrificed himself so maybe it's an even
it's only green goblin maybe it's
well yeah but he kind of means he died
like died in the moment but he but
talkback was literally he beat toby he
beat toby and then went i got to stop
what i'm doing let me take this power
thing and go into the river he didn't
[ __ ] try my hands to smile
but now now i'm that leads me to think
more that it's an evil doctor strange
convincing him they all died at your
hand to give him a problem like like
like get in his head like maybe maybe
that is evil doctor strange trying to
get in tom holland's head
so in the trailer well thank you dan
austin mate so in the trailer for brazil
there's a few friends it looks like the
lizard was punched by something that was
edited out yep man don't you know these
spidey faces they dissect every little
thing you can't do that [ __ ] man
connie's saying just dropping to say hi
but you remember connie from when we met
her at doom she's great amazing amazing
woman lovely
she's giving us the amazing headphones
you see us rocking in every video
i'll pull out all the wires but they're
nice and the very nice mics will
eventually upgrade too as well yes and
we have these very nice mics but we
haven't figured out how to properly
install it yet given a true moment to
sit down
when we have a live stream that isn't
hastily assembled we will set them up
and she's just a sweetheart and we over
dinner
uh el dantastico was that a hop goblin
there no it was not don't ask about that
and if it is there then great surprise
on you sony mike tillman i'm going to be
disappointed if toby andrew aren't in it
but i think it will still be a great
movie if they are i have certain
expectations with all this hype now look
we need to face reality here guys we got
villains from toby and andrews movies
directly pulled from their universes
coming together of course they're going
to be in it guys or
are they i have a question what if they
get pulled into our universe and they're
not it's very possible with the story so
far that they are i hope they do like a
deadpool 2 thing where they get pulled
in and just die right away
my big question is is that maybe what
they're doing with electro is electro
maybe not the tasm electro because he is
so so heavily overhauled
no i think there's obviously one thing
they allude to here and this is where
we're gonna get some real theorizing
going is they showed that with doc ock
he's suddenly able to absorb the
nanotech from uh peter's iron spider
suit so you do see a shot and it's in
the thumbnail for the marvel
entertainment world
you got a blue dot you got a blue
electro so there's going to be some type
of thing with the mcu with this
technologically wise where he could
actually look a little bit human now oh
that's a good point and then perhaps
that's what causes a conversion with the
colors as well
total total insane theory again i know
nothing more uh than you guys but what
if the second
the post-credits scene the second one
is teasing toby and chase movie oh sorry
and there's there's a fourth movie like
what if there's a sony spider-verse
movie that's like that's gonna happen
and then we don't get them in the movie
it ends on a cliffhanger and we tease
them there and that's the shot the dick
shot
it's just toby's dick just dick i saw
that at bulge i knew it was him
but like what if there isn't them in
this movie and we get another one well
then the movie just has to be an actual
the thing is i love the things koi says
to tamper expectations
if they are in the movie it'll be
amazing to behold but if they're not in
the movie the movie actually just has to
be good and it looks good so
it looks great i mean
i think it's going to be better than far
from home and homecoming i i really i
genuinely believe that it it's bringing
the elements in it that i've wanted in
terms of this looks like dark and
serious and heavy yeah with some
interesting comedy yeah there's still
like the fine humor of spider-man but
it's also like a different it looks like
empire i feel like the first half will
have a lot of humor yeah but i think
it's gonna progress into something
exceptionally dude that rain shot that
opens the trailer is just exactly
spider-man to me yeah i've seen john it
was a john mayer jr piece that happened
the last half felt a lot like spider-man
like the spider-man that i've kind of
grown up with yeah the last half
especially i can't wait i'm excited like
four weeks away
i know tickets are on monday let's fight
to the death spider monday let's fight
to the death for them let's break a pool
queue in half and fight i don't think
i'm gonna try to get tickets
i'm not gonna even [ __ ] try it
this is gonna be a stampede
in the world is gonna keep that from
being chaos i didn't know what avengers
end game was like dude that was like
insane there was no point in even waking
up
just want to say love you guys love you
too tyler man gave me a ps4 a while ago
what he did
tyler you're great and all i have to do
is send a photo of my dick well toby's
dick but not mine
oh and chase
i really hope hashtag toby's dick is
just like a permanent part of the
culture chase gardner can you guys
recreate the spider-man skit with koi
make koi wear the spider-man suit love
that skit thank you chase
yeah it would have been nice to have
cool put it on you're not wearing it
right now what if there was a uh some
sort of squidward
what if the multiverse and here we are
that's going to be our movie review
sketch schrodinger's gonna be like come
on guys
can you just sit in the whole sketch
dude now it's done
one reference is not a joke that's why
free brick and seltzer movies don't work
coy texted one joke and thought it was a
skit and now he's still doing it by
himself don't worry that's how i write
sketches
marley villas
uh marley villasonaire doctor strange
still seems i'll be out of character
thank you marley by the way do you think
it's john watts direction or is it not
this doctor strange that we know that
we've talked a little bit about in the
stream could be dark supreme strange or
could be the fact that he just has an
ideological difference with peter on how
to handle these villains that have
crossed over here maybe he's trying to
help the villains just get back home or
keep them safe or something i also trust
john watts his characterizations have
been really solid he's a good director
and i mean benedict cumberbatch isn't
going to play something that would
betray his character so at the end of
the day there's a brain trust of all
these actors and and let's not forget
the [ __ ] marvel committee dude
obviously that's what we need
there's doctor strange they're going to
talk to strangers
but like you know they're talking to
those actors and the big directors that
all share the power so like john watts
wouldn't do something that would
sacrifice uh the character so i i don't
think it's a directing thing i think
mischief is a foot yeah very true
all right john moving on up
john i love when john discovered the
poll option oh yeah he [ __ ] kills he
kills those polls hey man there's so
many people voting it's very gratifying
rachel fondura thank you rachel
i think the andrew leake is from that
big fight uh moments before that big
fight i'm groot
so good at different
and that's what we call oh pivot
[Laughter]
today thank you rachel
sebastian art you know when you do that
[ __ ] it just makes it seem like you know
something we don't know
before you know that
it doesn't seem like at all subtle
what if he sneezed
with sebastian rc wow that's a really
big super chat thank you man that's
really generous of you oh
uh final call no refunds uh they're not
even going to toms ha ha ha
definitely they were deleted
what what does that mean like out of the
trailer
they were they're not even going to toms
hahaha definitely they were deleted
they're not even going to holland
universe they're not in tom holland's
top eight on myspace
yeah they're not even they're not even
going to tom's uh home
i i got nothing guys i don't know
it's such a generous super chat
[ __ ] man i really want to know what the
hell you're trying to say right now
maybe they're not coming to tom's
universe i don't know they got deleted
on the way into the times you don't know
i don't know or they were delete or
maybe that's what you're trying to say
is like they're not even going they
deleted them out of the movie maybe
sony got so mad they said [ __ ] you guys
no we're taking them out
together in silence here we are all
righty uh james franco james franco who
was it
i don't think james franco was gonna be
in this guy
he's due for a comeback we we forget
about that stuff after a year
anissa oliva together in science by the
way
anissa oliva thank you so much it's been
so long
one of our og supporters and one of our
live stream dedicated there's been times
where she's given us like five hundred
dollars and we've been like
anissa please i once had to contact her
to be like are you sure you know what
you're doing
are you going to drive yourself into
intense debt you can't climb out of it
it reaches the point it's easy
so much that i'm like you might want to
are you sure you want to do they make it
easy to send these have you taken a look
at your bank balance
that zero go there or there that is very
kind uh okay the hey guys missed you all
do you think the ending do you know how
to do a texas accent
hey guys no
you think the ending where dr strange
says they're coming through
do y'all really think it is toby and
andrew and is it enough of a hint for
all of us
love you guys they [ __ ] know that you
know it's so chill
i was trying to i don't know i got you
two syllables before i bailed i didn't
even get the end of it i could do it
again
i could do it again as matthew
mcconaughey
trailer traditional
talk yes
whatever they do the logo
right whenever they do the logo and then
whatever the scene is added on after
it's either one of two things it's
either a funny scene to have a great
button on your trailer yes or it's a
major tease of what's to come and that's
always what it is but something funny or
a major tease and so when they had that
moment what else could dr strange be
talking about maybe king the conqueror
maybe aeroshem maybe
yeah it's just going to be more
celestial i just wanted to be that
[ __ ] druid
we're done not interfering all right
you guys
i wanted this captain american shield
built a long time ago
what was up with that building like what
do you guys think that is it's the
statue of liberty and they're adding the
captain america shield onto it
that's good to know coidiferous john
drow now if it was the captain marvel
shield that'd be woke yep two oh yeah no
no
we're on the right shield you can't do
that let's see because i i i this yeah
it's america's shield yeah no no i know
that i just didn't connect it to the to
the uh
liberty yeah when the construction's all
falling look they have a photo right
there hey look at this yeah i was asking
about it it's literally yeah it's
literally the statue of liberty with the
captions things and here i am seeing the
image i had no idea that's actually
great
i'm into that okay full support that's
exciting it was the peggy carter one
we'd have a problem yeah i mean we got
to talk about it uh here we go
i don't like your wealthiest man
all my french
statues statue representing american
friendships
they were very generous in building us
that lady liberty is american icon made
in france
hi india we got indy in the chat
don't worry we don't want any visuals
today um it would be crazy if james
franco came back though bobby bobby it
would be a certain kind of crazy lambeam
i've been watching you guys since i was
15. i'm now 20 and i still love your
guys's content congrats to koi for the
hosting opportunity all of you are
killing it well the only reason koi got
the opportunity is because i saw him on
our morbius trailer reaction obviously
that's our guy and they said i don't
know who those two homeless guys are but
that guy that clean shaven white fella
he should be hosting our review he's
sure excited about morbius let's give
him a call i feel like he may or may not
know spider-man
[Music]
uh i gotta go live from this interface i
got to tell it to feed into youtube
let's see what happens maybe it'll think
and it'll hey
are we back are we back
we're back are we okay are we back dude
john did it
i so wish i could just play lonely
islands we're back right now that's all
that's all i want look in my vape
i think it's okay don't worry about it
don't worry the people know average view
time on this forever live stream is two
minutes and 49 seconds all right that
means people only gone koi you got to be
more interested i really gotta upload
it's on me guys i'm sorry i was doing my
song
nation and it's on me okay pause that
playback all right yeah yeah let's let's
finish up the rounds here so that way we
can do it thank you guys for waiting on
us sorry about that like i said we got
we've been
basically we've covered a lot of shows
we want to have thanksgiving and black
friday off and especially black friday
the supply chain you guys
we're trying to have just a couple of
days off and i'm going to comic-con like
a fool so we're just trying to uh yeah
it's black friday for nerd information
that's true you know
yeah you know but since we uh since we
logged off for a little bit is there a
way we can pull up the um the uh
brazilian trailer and watch that live
can they hear it or like you put it in
this one can you put it in a small
screen
i don't
know if i can
uh put sound in it but no no no don't
worry about it right now
as long as we can hear it i can get you
some brazilian twitter you can make it
i'm sure doesn't have a youtube channel
it's not the same as the one that's on
twitter if you want the one that has
like the phantom punch and all that jazz
that's on twitter
it's not on their youtube i listened to
aaron and olivia go over that like a
bunch all right so yeah let's find it on
the twitter one all right we're going
you're looking for the brazilian trailer
to watch in full
can you guys hit that like button
because we [ __ ] up
can you save us can you save us by
hitting that like button
and uh oh you know what a bunch of
people in the chat have also been saying
that strange could be a scroll maybe
although coy
would a scroll strange have magical
abilities i would argue that a skrull
strange would have limited visual
abilities like they could make things uh
like maybe near his person up here but i
think if you disconnected from the
person it's like mystique like it's
gotta be on you so i feel like the
actual magic couldn't possibly work
unless it was like mysterio-esque and
that it was contained and it's not so uh
i don't think he's a scroll i also feel
like there's gonna be uh
a big push for scroll stuff after this
actually instead of watching that john
can you go down a little bit i want to
see what those photos are
we're trying to find these photos we're
going through like you know what some
people john would you click stuff i'm
sorry no john i don't ask a lot of you
during the stream we only ask you to set
up the camera set up the live stream
reconnect us back to the live stream
monitor
monitor the super chats
make sure all the sound is good
it's really fun
when when we got a third person in the
room it's really fun to be in this chair
it's just when it melts down or when
there's like a mystery additional audio
track i just don't understand why
pictures what picture were you looking
for photos okay
photos votes mcgoats votes mcgoats
photos this is where you get the juicy
stuff where people put some [ __ ] like is
it this is it this
is it
thanks squad for suggesting the
livestream it's just fun
guys
before we went live i was like koi i got
a major migraine i don't know if i want
to go live i do these are fun these are
fun when you get there
we conserved energy we saved up we did
the damn thing all right let's get some
game
let's see what we got here if there's
anything special here oh it's just those
photos i made john go through all that
work just to discover that it was the
same photos that we had
ourselves
literally this free jets point
look at that point
yeah
you know he's totally getting hit by
something man yeah
all right we should definitely bring
back up those uh we should definitely
bring back up those super chats since we
[ __ ] maybe you could pivot five
minutes there were some people who were
like i said my super chat and now i'm
going to get red nah nah everyone gets
red we don't we no sleep till everyone's
red
and uh no uh witcher either got this
john yeah right sorry guys okay richard
stephanie janja the hottest mom in the
world is in the live stream mommy great
and that makes me uncomfortable but i'm
very happy that your beauty transferred
to mine so i can do a job where i'm on
camera and be as narcissistic as i am
dude koi is so beautiful thank you mama
gendro stephanie you are so hot jon
this is john
it's just it's really good that i have
such good friends that don't make me
feel uncomfortable think about her
constantly and it's just here we go the
only reason i got close to koi was to
get close to stephanie it's the stacy's
mom of it all i respect you stacy here i
respect coy i hear an object i respect
everyone in the room here there's the
clip out you guys are looking for it i'm
craig objectifying my mother live on air
is how things go i'm like hey my mom
really enjoyed the the skit you guys
made and then greg returns the favor
with pure awareness
really enjoy your mom's sisters you know
what i wouldn't be here without her and
here we go
here we are
sorry a
always in our streams love it
uh denosity mate no we got that we got
that go up
go up
slower slower uh
slower go up go up go up i got you john
uh up up up up uh stop slow slow uh cj
they're right there cg tj toby is going
for electro and andrew for lizard uh or
the other way around tom is going for
sandman's punch see i thought of anyone
sandman might be like the one who's kind
of on the good side especially after the
end of that one yeah where he's like i
done [ __ ] up
[Laughter]
together john you're the one throwing
this off i mean i was looking at that
shot and i was like oh sandman in this
kind of looks like simon callow or
something like are we going to see
thomas hayden church at all or just the
sandman forum and are we going to see
reese's fans at all or just the lizard
form that would suck if we don't
i think we might have just villain like
like full lizard like like it might not
even be thomas hayden he might not even
be involved at all like what are you
talking about sandman is usually in and
he what's his name uh
marco frank grillo
you can see where i got flynn marco from
honestly
if you can't play
games if you can't pull flynn marco
after hannah you're like there's a freak
ruler you gotta there's a simple there's
an after
yes i think uh i think flint marco uh
he's usually in human form that's what
we're saying is not here because he's
like this big billowy force of nature
yeah and his his sand form doesn't
exactly evoke thomas hayden church here
oh we got to talk about this people in
the chat are talking about it right now
this very second and we owe a little bit
of extra time for [ __ ] up earlier we
got this one right uh i was 15 and i'm
totally okay but really quick and the
chat people are discussing this right
now um they're they're talking about how
when mj falls john brought this up and i
noticed a lot of other comps for
bringing this up too is how people think
that's when andrew garfield might step
and get a little bit of a redemption
moment after failing to save gwen stacy
and he goes in and says mj once again
showing
that you know tom holland just needs a
little bit of extra help you know you
got to learn
now the thing about it is tom holland's
learning he's new he's sorting it out i
love that idea um i think it's a great
moment because you've gotta if they're
in the movie it has to be such a moment
and that would be story that would be
action that would be like yeah that
sounds great
if that's a possibility sold it's
classic spider-man you know one yeah
woman falling to her death spidey has to
save her body's got to be there
he's right there saving lives most the
time all right here we go chase way the
leak open to do chase
uh the leak of toby and andrew with the
green screen behind and the metal bars
matches up with that lizard scene yes it
does
achoo am i right i think groot is in the
scene because the thing about guardians
galaxy 3's timing is they've just
started filming you've got a christmas
shoe that ties together in as well so
perhaps this being a holiday film tying
into the guardians galaxy 3 christmas
special i feel like james gunn
incorporating group really allows us to
merchandise across different platforms
would you shut the [ __ ] up i just think
it's good
pikachu vampint
it was ant-man lizard was hit by ant-man
now that would be awesome
it's an actual bait and switch for us
like we they know people are gonna
scrutinize frame by frame be like i bet
that's a cgm
and it's literally in the story as
ant-man i would love that yeah and i
wouldn't be disappointed at all jake
peterson greg where's the nipple chills
bro i get nipple i i i forgot to call my
nipple chills i'm sorry did you get
episodes in the trailer yeah i did yeah
yeah i did nice [ __ ] did man i made
you know what got me nipple chills was
actually um uh talk saying uh you're
you're not peter you're not peter for
some reason that was the moment
that was the moment i was like oh
chilling so i i'll share this with you
guys that no one else will ever know now
all of you will uh in the audience of it
was just sony exec sony exec security
and then all the security i walked
through i wasn't thinking and i'm so
used to reacting like i do at home so i
was watching the trailer and i kept like
cheering and going oh and i was like oh
they've hired me and i'm doing this as
my first impression and it i couldn't
not like i was so invested in the
trailer but it was a really weird vote
where i was like i'm a professional here
for the job
and um hopefully i get to work with them
boy people don't like stiff ass boring
people
they want someone who can connect and be
a fan as well that's why you're there
that's why you're the man cory you guys
i just didn't realize till it was over
that that might be not how most people
watch trips you're a passionate fan
you're not some boring access hollywood
host i mean but access hollywood if
you're looking to hire someone if you're
wondering not boring hosts yeah
you're not boring hosting all right
you're not wrong drew makowsky i feel
like it's andrew spider-man reaching for
the hand lol i don't know aaron and
olivia spent a great deal of time
scrutinizing that the hand itself and uh
and they still wound up split although i
think there's a fairly
i don't know in the visual language of
that moment i feel like
unless they're cutting to a totally
different scene it looks especially like
his hand yeah he's he's facing downward
with the
trajectory of yeah i've even got a
visual aid of that right i would love if
all of these shots are fake outs like
endgame did like a couple times if like
some of these things are literally for
us to have these conversations
oh they they must like that'd be they've
also talked about spider-man with the
doctor strange uh
magic
it's pretty difficult spider-strange
strange
strange
spragic
oh there you go there you go see he's
reaching down he's reaching and then the
hand shot is very clearly
the down
no that moment should go to tom holland
yeah i think it should go to tom holland
because he's gotta catch her initially
and maybe andrew helps maybe right
before she snaps her neck on the bottom
of the ground yeah yeah he just lays out
a webcam
yeah
you're good you're good yeah you're good
uh i yeah i hope tom gets i just feel
like self-actualizing is so important
for spider-man mythos so i hope he gets
to succeed and we get to see the
evolution of spider-man's we got some
things to climb through here let's keep
it going guys
t-magic infinity based on this new
trailer i think there will be one or two
major deaths in the movie
i think uh i i suspect
i suspect since they're evidently
borrowing from one more day that they
would kill off aunt may but maybe bring
her back also in the same [ __ ] movie
i know she's still young and hot i mean
what about like stephanie
all
right
uh what about i think maybe ned
do you know something we don't know i
feel like groot would really say oh my
gosh
get along well they're both like the guy
in their chair of their own universes
the support system a tree allowed let's
move on to that super chat
so i know venom is in the mcu now is he
is he
or do you were they pulling peter
the venom spider or yeah spiders in a
different universe altogether where both
tom holland and venom simultaneously
i mean no way schroedinger's venom do
you think venom will be in this movie if
so is he team spider team six i think
he'll be teased in a post-credits scene
tom holland's gonna see him on a tv and
lick it
he's actually
thirsty
on venom right now we're like that's
exactly right
that's exactly what we want
man those screen links
oh thank you dress um
yeah sorry john please no in the current
iteration i feel like venom would show
up and be like oh i must help the spider
guy
yeah
you know he's a big cookie monster he's
a mental protector
i also noticed
that you guys are there oh you must hope
the spider
he goes down a little bit here he's a
little cookie monster yeah
cookie monster
in the stream
that's the next thing they're going to
argue about venom 3.
i'll make sure i ask him the question
were you inspired by pokemon
that's i'm gonna go with my tom hardy
from now on i mean you're tom hardy let
me give you a practice why do nuts
you know he's a human head monster as he
spartans i also noticed the electrodes
and the lizard's trajectory are a bit
off almost as if they're jumping at
something else or is it just me it's not
just you in fact if i could pull one up
quickly i would and i don't know if i
could but on twitter there are so many
you know ms paint drawn arrows
what the [ __ ] are they talking about oh
in the scene where they're all jumping i
knew this live stream was going to take
hours you know hours you knew this was
coming and you hours of support would be
coming our way yeah you know hours of
people sons of [ __ ] people's
interests
when i could be working a regular
nine-to-five job at the grocery store
but here i am talking about things i
love due to your support
the worst people in the world showing
their support here so people are
surmising that that tow that tom is is
lunging at the fist because there's that
connecting shot there where it makes
sense maybe it's iron fist ever thought
about that yeah danny rain uh
yeah
[Laughter]
that is my favorite joke to come out of
this whole thing
teeny
i
mean they i want to clip that and make
it like a like an audio gif but
like the way that they've been taking
these new phase this new phase and using
it as partially an opportunity to touch
back on old movies that weren't as well
received i would love if they did that
for the netflix like for the you know
iron fists of the world where it's like
we won't even really have a reason to do
jesus christ guys can we people think
that uh andrew is lunging against the
lizard here and that uh and
somebody is is lunging up here probably
that's basically what the oh yeah no
that speculation that would be you got
three you got three going up there and i
i spider-man wouldn't lunge at all three
of them no yeah
like even in comics and [ __ ] when
spider-man's fighting the sinister six
he doesn't go after all
a group of them at once or if he was two
i feel like he would be like shooting a
a blast yeah some kind of web concoction
and then
it will go well
i'm going to ignore two of you and just
take on one it's fine yeah yeah totally
oh yeah yeah yeah absolutely abstract
media turns out all those leaks
go warren yeah he's gonna be feeling
even the conflicting links even
conflicting reports are true you [ __ ]
call me out on this video yeah yeah
you're gonna let that slide
oh yeah i gotta fix my comment it won't
show up cause it's a block keyword you
[ __ ] go find [ __ ] warren go find every
leak video that hasn't come true yet and
rub him in his face yeah i'm gonna be
like here's everything go wrong before
yeah [ __ ]
hey hidden marvel 21 thank you for the
moment of silence i really do appreciate
that ooh here's a an interesting one
from rob colfer will coy be taking tom
comic shopping you know the thing about
tom holland is he's very busy and very
nice and
i i would like if tom holland stayed
both busy and nice
okay yeah that makes sense yeah yeah so
kevin that probably yeah
but if he stays busy and he stays nice
that means the best possible outcome is
that he'll want to do it but regrettably
be too busy
poor guys it's sometimes good to keep
people busy is what i'm saying you
should keep and if they're nice you'll
want to keep keeping them busy with it
joshie boys studios happy dies in that
car calling it now
oh just the option moments pre explosion
i love happy he's so great i would be so
unhappy if he had me if he died i don't
think he dies in that scene
how do you guys feel about electro suit
love it we need to see a little bit of
different because they showed a shot
that if you slow it down of like jamie
foxx john let's pull it up let's
criticize coy you be positive you know
how to do this yeah i got standard
issues
[Laughter]
i haven't been awake for half of this
saturday
find that shot of electro where they
close up on jamie foxx we gotta get that
shot okay definitely he's blue there so
yeah he changes all right we're going
through this
we're going through this you got this
john i believe in you so much
oh my god you're doing such a great job
yeah yeah oh yeah remix that [ __ ] yeah
oh there it is okay there yeah yeah go
back go back to go back a little more
yeah oh you want this first a little bit
yeah yeah wanna see his face
so it looks like very cartoony a little
bit uh hugo weaving matrix reloaded neo
um but uh maybe it'll be better in the
actual context where it won't be
distracting i wanted to see a little bit
of jamie foxx
uh where it's uh not like a cgi moment i
wanted to see him like not cgi because
the most we got from jamie foxx was this
very evident cgi animated moment of him
you know but there's a moment where he
shoots and he goes like full doctor
manhattan so i'm curious like how much
his power levels gone up and like
whether or not we true like it so i
don't know if we're gonna get a more
human or more metahuman like i don't
know if we'll get those moments because
it seems like we're leaning and
everyone's super powered like at the
peak of their powers like sandman like
we talked about yeah well i really like
this that yeah it's like way more
stripped back and it looks just like a
electric circuitry and stuff like that
looks like a guy built it yeah yeah it
looks like some guy built it out of
power plant scraps you know
that's so cool
which is the character and the comic
iteration i mean he's got the it's it's
fascinating to me because he's got the
most different makeover from everyone
well that's why i'm asking is like i
don't know lizard looks the same with
that character from that movie who got
his tooth gap fix be like let me get a
goatee let me grow my yeah it looks like
a cool class jamie foxx
is awesome yeah he had a comb over in
that movie yeah what if there's two
electrodes like what if we you know if
we're going through the multiverses what
if there's a blue electro and that's the
sinister circle yeah
like what if andrew shows up and he's
like wait but that
that's kind of electro but that's not
who i know you know like because we
could always have that option of not
just multiple like there's it's a
multiverse so i can see yeah i can see
there being some madness to come of that
yeah i feel like madness would ensue
it's freaking war and i called him a
[ __ ] and now he's saying [ __ ] warning
my texts and he won't go into my live
stream and say it
eric voss said who is correct text i've
been texting every texting [ __ ]
warren thompson dude we've been looking
for boss in the chat this whole time
damn
come on warren
call me he'll warn you to catch warren
in a taylor swift video oh really yeah
he's in the video oh wow yeah man
she's singing about him come on warren
warren really broke taylor's warren
attacked me in a video
he's going down taylor why'd you go in
like that
and hey did you manny rodriguez wants to
know did you see electro attack doc ock
because that's a lot like warren and you
attacking each other right there it's
happening live you guys got to
understand i love the [ __ ] out of warren
he does would you call me out in a video
and prove me wrong
that hurts my feelings we'll see we'll
see
no warren's an amazing amazing guy he's
going to be coming out to california
again soon we were talking about meeting
up and maybe going to a theme park
together oh that's fun yeah so it's fun
yeah man morning in the background of
one of his videos you sent me yeah yeah
yeah when i first spotted you guys on a
carpet it's just me yelling no i want
you and warren i want you and more to
like do a video together yeah he seems
like a nice guy i think he would really
like talking with that man i really do
come out you guys haven't had an actual
conversation i've only said what am i
doing i'm talking nice about him screw
that card
who doesn't think he is got to keep the
bit up yeah 46 of people in the chat
think that andrew is going to save
zendaya and that she wouldn't die in
this movie i'm not going to lie i'm i'm
trying not to act like how [ __ ] cool
i thought it was that eric boss was in
her slacks
but not too much attention but that's
[ __ ] crazy to me both new robs oh new
rock stars and uh erik voss on separate
accounts yeah it's crazy man wow that's
that's really touching absolutely guys
screenshotted them both epic hero shop
you got to get some of their mercs
[ __ ] comfortable as [ __ ] and their
awesome designs get their latest
obsessions all that jazz all right here
we go manny rodriguez did you guys see
electro attack dot [ __ ] did not did not
and i hunted this moment down
we're literally looking at the chat
right now somewhere
apparently i'm your third favorite white
guy
third favorite white guy warren
warren thompson
wonderfully white warren it goes koi
aaron warren paul from fv spoilers
eric vaught no no eric voss paul from
every spoilers
john
you got to keep him you got to collect
them you got to make sure no andrew
gordon then john i'm your eighth
favorite way guys warren we haven't met
but i'm the background one of your
videos you guys met briefly for a second
oh we did right after that video yeah it
was like hello this is this is easy yeah
man very very very well dressed nice
suit cosmic wonder check out his
breakdown he does a great job just don't
get to 15 20 in that video where he
calls me out just drop it 15 18.
get out don't go to 15 20. skip that
part and go to 15 25. skip ahead yeah
i hope we all stay a community after
spider-man no way home because it seems
like heavy spoilers 3c films new rock
stars uh cosmic wonder
all of us have kind of been this cool
collective community i think spider-man
no way home really brought a lot of us
together yeah man it's kind of like the
multiverse
channels together spiderman all right
jordan garza uh did john just say he's
going hard in that suit absolutely
there's no other way to go when you're
crammed into a children's spider-man
costume you go going hard is the entire
point question koi did you get uh an
erection during the panel
uh with tom holland well i mean he's
very dashing but i made that suit though
i mean goddamn and i was like and he
changed that into that suit so like in
front of you and i was like yo let's
talk about andrew and toby he's like i'm
changing bro get out of my changing room
um that's where you signed the nda yeah
it was a really weird encounter
altogether i'm shocked it went as well
as it did uh he came in like was in a
very like nice sweater and i was like oh
i dressed appropriately and then the
next time i saw him use a suit and i was
like i brought a change of clothes and i
did not have time to change that and now
i feel like a fool um but the answer to
your question is no comment i got you
all right
marcus adams got home from work just in
time for this i've been looking for you
guys reaction ever since i saw the
trailer really appreciate that marcus
adams oh god guys the stream's done
before again we're done for it again
we're done it's really dark okay never
mind immediately it's really dark in the
multiverse thank you so much marcus for
your support buddy thank you let's keep
this going abstract media also lizard to
being punched by no one being punched by
hopes
maybe his neck just started hurting it
is the biggest thing
yeah he's just going guys if we all do a
big move together maybe i can get this
kink out of my neck i gotta go to the
chiropractor freaking three-minute
trailer and the most common talked about
thing is
lizard punch wizard in the obscure
brazilian cut of this on twitter only
unonly twitter yeah thank you abstract
media reuben uh hear me out commissioner
jameson i like the way that sounds i
like that a lot cause it reminds me of
alcohol and spider-man and batman five
of my favorite things alcohol spider-man
spider-man alcohol dude you know
actually spider-man's not allowed to
hold alcohol in the comic books so
there's comic books where deadpool and
spider-man team up in the sbc holding
soda and the label has to be out
deadpool's allowed to drink spider-man's
not that's even as an adult yep wow that
character is so whole he's a team
yeah he's he's totally tea
i only have organic webs someone's
saying poke the trailer go to 159 all
right all right all right here we go we
got it but then we really gotta speed
through this yeah speed two go back to
two dots
why doesn't go to 159 what's up 159 go
back a little bit more
right there what was this moment
referring to oh yeah this is a moment
that people were talking about a lot i
don't know what i'm looking for here
because i saw someone putting aaron
storm in the chat just pointed this out
what's the weird thing here that people
are pointing out i saw this i saw photos
of this and i was like what are people
talking about here though it looks like
peter is evading a lightning bolt
yeah that's what we're supposed to see
but there's like some hidden thing here
that i just cannot know i don't know
what the [ __ ] they're talking about
where they have a theory about it can
someone in the chat say what a what it
might be i mean i can blow despite
popular belief we are looking at the
actual live stream chat
i can uh make this bigger
and go to the other view
yeah what are we looking at here
i don't see anything weird about this
shot
looks like it's pulling him spiderman
looks like the shot's in reverse like
it's pulling him all right then no no no
no no it's not because he crabs onto
them and then it launches him yeah okay
go back i don't know what's mysterious
about this shot i don't i don't know
what it is spiderman i saw this shot
going around a lot and i can't see what
was strange about it live chat tell us
i don't know what's happening live see
if anyone point anything out
where's
sorry you know me and we're like an
eminem song
toby's suit eyes the eyes okay let's see
okay let's look at the eyes we're gonna
pull it back here one more time people
are saying his eyes all right all right
pull back one more time just look like
toby's eyes
okay so we're back
go slow go slow go frame by frame john
i guess yeah kinda
i mean they're big i mean tom tom's eyes
have those shutters on them that adjust
for lights but at the same time i mean
toby's are like the big ones right
uh
i feel like
that is the kid from amazing spider-man
2 dressed as spider-man and those are
his eyes and what we're seeing in is the
multiverse of that kid and frankly at
the end of the day this is too big of a
spoiler to really dive into and i'm a
little uncomfortable because that is
clearly the child that rhino tried to
kill oh yeah oh yeah and that's also the
kid who ended up being tom holland
spider-man well it's also the kid that
robert downey jr means that one stark
expo that turns out to be tom holland so
actually what's crazy about wait look so
there's the lecturer shot down that's
what i was saying he's got dr manhattan
he's a doctor manhattan and then he goes
into that that's what i was saying he
forms into this suit he doesn't do that
in uh in uh doesn't he he does at the
end of the last time like he doesn't
need to like go into the grid yeah in
the last fight so i'm saying but he
forms this so maybe those are keeping
them together kind of like uh like in
some comics there's gonna be one of
those yeah because he looks
right there's gonna be one of those
scenes where he winds up in new york and
then he's like walking along and he sees
like a different guy's haircut and then
he sees like another dude's outfit and
he's like i need a makeover yeah he's
like i'm gonna be cool
cool all righty
just
live and it's just you don't need it
or even ask permission i'm sure
generally
[Laughter]
probably has i mean
check it against the batman but it's got
to have right
toby's eyes in the shot yeah i mean it
kind of looks like toby's eyes good bean
even warren texted me thanks for keeping
me up to date buddy
what's up guys at the end of the trailer
doctor strange says they're coming and i
cannot stop it what do y'all believe
he's speaking of it's poop he has to
poop really bad and he can't stop it
they're coming out you know honestly
there's no stopping i gotta take a [ __ ]
that's where he's holding the other
that's why that's why he's in the torch
is because you know he wants to curse
the darkness and at least it'll cover it
allows a certain amount of coverage
all right oh yes you know who we think
it is guys we sent her in during the
reaction yeah oh dcu abstract media back
at it okay last one i bet when's the day
of falls clearly refers to the amazing
spider-man 2 andrew wrestles her when
tom can't catch her in time redeems
himself for gwen that is a popular
opinion i might i at first i really love
that but i'm actually hoping that it
ends up being tom holland the story
element who does it
well all right warren keep commenting
man yeah i feel like it would mean the
most if it's if it's tom's whole thing i
again like i could see some kind of
cheeky andrew involvement but he can't
just flat out save her
willy zhang sorry guys miles morales is
breaking through i could pull up the
live chat here on my phone too what if
it's just the entire cast of
spider-verse you know they're all there
as their human selves though the cage is
like hey there we go oh nice i'm
spider-man
all right willie zhang sorry guys uh
miles morales is breaking through i just
realized you think so oh you did i'm
sorry
never caught up
he could be who knows actually we should
do this more often if we have the
trailer up and we have to give people
who have like time stamps for to check
[ __ ] out that's pretty cool i love it i
love that idea
okay a lot of people are saying 230 why
are people saying 230 goblin
green goblin upgrades oh no we went over
that earlier guys we did we did
john dropped the the mic i'm looking at
your live stream chat on my phone too
since we have like multiple chat things
going is it uh the 230s that that's only
the goblin thing right i believe that is
the goblin thing okay
yeah we did go over that at the very top
like very early on in the stream
oh yeah we want to reveal that
no warren you should be going to
avengers campus with us too
pull up 2 30 really quick 2 30. yeah
since we have ended the super chats
uh i mean we have more super chats to go
through and that's hanging off a
building look over 2 30 go back go back
what are we looking at here this is not
the goblin moment no it's not at all
what are we supposed to notice at 2 30.
guys point out to us tell us in the chat
right now i'm looking at it right now
what are we supposed to notice
oh the polls and [ __ ] this is where the
andrew garfield thing was was that yeah
yeah yeah oh yeah yeah we were talking
about that and that's ned's hanging off
here and mj's falling down and then toe
pete uh willie mcguire has a comment
that can't be shown it says you're trash
but you're bullied mcguire i gotta let
that be shown oh yeah okay yeah sand in
your eye
got it
all right i heard there's a chance for
another trailer let's keep going guys
all right
we got we gotta honor this absolutely i
know i'm the worst you said no one would
be here
any post-credit theories from bj
possibly venom maybe a miles appearance
okay so here's my question we already
said that we think there'll be a venom
one coy do you have a quick one you can
spit ball but what a doctor strange one
might be i think it might be tying in uh
that he is in fact evil and how the
ramifications of that have caused the
multiverse of madness so it'll be kind
of an inciting incident of us seeing the
beginning of multiverse about us where
things are colliding in the events of
this movie led to a more problematic
bigger mcu incident so it'll be a
cliffhanger in the doctor strange world
that kind of starts here so it's
probably not going to end well right all
right john pull it back up the trailer
201 let's look at that i'm reading this
in the chat you guys
wait 2 30 they're saying you could see
andrew's arm we already pointed out a
shot where you could see andrew's arm
groot uh i don't see andre's arm in the
shot 2 30.
i'm not seeing any andrew arms here no
we don't see any andro arms
i don't see anything
we're trying to spot andrew arms
nothing there
yeah get hit
it's real i don't know what you guys are
talking about
i don't know i don't know what you see
right now we're not trying to be causing
wonder in real time you can't be cause
we wonder he's an anomaly that cosmic
wonder he's unbeatable no one knows what
he's going to do next is unpredictable
all right so to go to 201 is what i
heard okay
electro attacks doc awk
let's see if we can see what they're
talking about
hold tight now because he's he is
completely exposed here and look at the
reverse he's being blasted out of a
building right so he's maybe he's on the
other side of the building like through
the building he gets them through like
all the way through the building yeah
okay sure yeah like right like there's
no reason he couldn't i mean who who's
blast would that be
well i mean that's fair so maybe doctor
strange i mean doc is good
yeah maybe he is helping them yeah
oh [ __ ] the first time i've seen him
damn great great call we should [ __ ]
do more live streams like this you guys
give us trailer moments to look at today
we got a live reaction our live
trailer we didn't see you didn't see our
reaction yeah
you heard our reaction yeah authentic
excitement happening live yeah because
the footage is playing yeah
audio commentary by us we're very
excited
damn good thank you guys all right john
yeah he goes check his dick okay check
his dick for the winner if it's really
required to check his neck yep
megan drummond thank you guys deaf
andrew garfield catching mj's hands
great way to do the live streams i
really appreciate it yeah
i mean yeah we don't know if that's
happening should we look at the hands no
no no no no no no we're going to knock
those [ __ ] man we got it we gotta move
on right now all right all right i had
so much adrenaline and now my body is
like i got you both yeah remember that
time when i was like i'm actually pretty
exhausted right now we should go live
though
this is how my biology works once
everyone else hits the wall i'm like
okay
it's 11 p.m let's get energy john's
ready the guy in the chair nick figures
or figures uh the lizard gets punched by
seemingly nothing in the brazil version
of the trailer during the wide shot of
three villains okay
i gotta find out i'm sorry i go to 228.
you know i gotta find out don't do this
all right i'm just not going to find you
i'll just leave all the suggestions of
moments i just gotta know really quick i
gotta know what they're saying in the
chat okay
here we go 228 where is andrew's hand we
are at 228. i don't see andrew's [ __ ]
hand anywhere you guys
i mean look at how big that look this is
a giant shield
he said we just passed it warren said
that go back
go back
go back keep going back like you've
never meant you'd like you wanted to go
back before yeah that makes sense you
see andrew's hand anywhere
we are at 220 hit the chat's yelling at
him 27. 220.
no go back go back to the preview the
frame before this one let's see let's
let's go slowly there
i'm in 227 right now
this is the first frame
go back go back how far back like out go
back before this shot okay
okay all right yeah andrew's hand's
definitely there that's it's holding a
torch
you guys are talking about where the
[ __ ] is this shot
i see debris i don't see an andrew
hannah anyways what the hell are you
guys talking about it would be so tough
okay so is the implication that it's
somewhere along here is it is it this
railing 228 left of ned
okay so it's the shot of ned hanging
over the edge then where
okay oh yeah yeah right there we pointed
this one at the very beginning of the
floor yeah that's at the very top of
this we put a whole freezer
put some trust in yeah this was like one
of the first things we talked about show
up at the beginning warren i've been
stressed out all day yeah it's just one
image
yeah
even hd
that's even clearer that that's a
[ __ ] i don't know man everybody we
have that crappy
wow that's even clearer
that is
what i love about that moment is it
looks like andrew garfield and helping
out with [ __ ]
he just left one of his sleeves he was
just like
let her fall i i know what it's like i
want that makeover
[Music]
because he's you know made of nature so
it conflicts with the magic all right
big
and partly
do you think mysterio is actually dead
and do you think he will show up in a
future movie do not think he's actually
dead not one bit not one part of you
know what he says
i think he's one of those no way dead is
hyped for this movie but did anyone else
feel like this trailer revealed a bit
much sony always seems to do this nah
man there's so much i think there's just
so much in this movie that's almost
three hours think about it it's three
minutes long and the other show is like
two and a half minutes long it's only
five and a half minutes worth of footage
out of a two and a half two hour and
forty minute movie and awesome tom
holland literally said this is the tip
of the iceberg and in this instance i
really believe him he was saying that
this is the most extravagant like
the way he described this is
consistent and this trailer seems to be
consistent with all the things we've
heard i think i think do you think it
looks better than uncharted um the thing
about uncharted is it's also a sony
property
and groot must be in it
uh i think that it seems to me like they
aren't really it seems like they're
pulling from a lot of the same moments
and even in this new trailer expanding
on them and it leads me to wonder if the
statue of liberty fight is actually not
the ultimate finale of the movie
i think it might be the second hour all
right level tv
i think mysterio is gonna be the sixth
villain not venom he'll be revealed
alive i feel venom will fight spider-man
in separate film like venom three we can
only hope for that show level tv but uh
i i don't know i think mysterio won't
even actually be in this movie to be
totally honest
casey mac i still want to know why
doctor strange saying torum is frozen
seems very slush
well it's owned by disney now so it's a
crossover
koi has
let the livestream go
111 to 113 audio could be cut from
different parts and could be doctor
strange uh saying there are others out
there referencing to other
uh when he says we
in that could it mean uh we need help
uh
yeah i thought about that show him
visually saying it so that's a very good
thing yeah i know it could be his lines
all chopped up and and yeah
oh yeah definitely a thousand percent
tony tedford all three i like that
dwayne the rock johnson i'm moving to la
in january i got hired at warner bros
congratulations i would love to buy
y'all a beer when i get there since i'll
need some new friends
i mean i'm all about that networking you
know i'm all about that climbing the
ladder let's create some opportunities
so you know man if there's ways to like
collaborate together if you're looking
for some influencers to work together
with then yeah especially at warner
brothers we like warner brothers man
what position you at i want to see the
batman's i don't want to slow anything
down
you show me the batman suit you got a
deal
batman suit this is batman screening uh
i don't want to slow things down but the
chat is commenting 212 and 211 a lot so
i don't know mj scar or something
something keep that in mind let's finish
adam hockenberry man what in the
zepruder film is this the greatest
marvel film of all time right next to
ghost right this is a pruder film the
perform's a really common reference
that's escaping me it's like a film it's
like a film kid joke oh damn it dave my
brain's fuzzy when it comes back prickle
it up dave donna i think that andrew
will save mj when she's falling
i maybe he'll help perhaps but it should
be talking he's grouped dc i wish that
people who complain about being spoiled
by trailers would stop talking about
trailers that's fair i don't think
trailers are as spoilery as they once
were have you ever seen a chat from like
the 70s it's the movie watch
watch the first trailer for like [ __ ]
rocky
they even show you like the fight
they go on to the point where you're
like okay and no stop thank you stop
going oh good god reacts to this this
doesn't yeah
no surprises to be had if you watch one
of those trailers molly g been a fan
since i was a teen how ecstatic are you
i'm very ecstatic what makes me more
ecstatic right now is coy was the one
between the three of us who was the most
insistent on doing a live stream okay
and now he's the one who's been kind of
crashing you know the adrenaline more
than all of us
never seen you in this state yeah
you know what i'm feeling it the woo
bastard you know i'm here
all righty willy plays i felt like if
andrew was in that frame he would have
been trying to say yeah
exactly that's what i found funny about
that moment it's like it looks like
someone cut him out but it also looks
like he's not doing [ __ ] about it yeah
yeah that would be weird i really hope
they [ __ ] ruined andrew garfield in
this room
hero yeah i don't know about them let's
see
audrey i saw some theories that happy or
someone else close to peter might die in
this movie what do you guys think and
hey comment on the poll because that's
what's up right now in the chat
is
is the one that seems like the most
likely most people think so too i think
there could be a death but i do think
it'll
be i think it'll stick unlike other
deaths like i think i think spider-man's
character is so tied to death and we
don't really have that with tom hollands
except for uh iron man and i think
they've been listening to the iron man
like iron man junior criticism so this
might be his gwen stacy moment this
might be his uncle ben moment this might
be his jonah like i don't know maybe
it'll be gwen stacy shows up in the last
half hour of this movie just to die just
the dice remember that bryce dallas
howard should be like oh hey if you're
happy but i'm going states you'll be
like oh my god be like i feel like this
is impactful
strife no other channel makes me smile
like
like new rosters
they're saying at 212 mj has a scar that
she doesn't have while she is falling
she lives
oh she lives that's a good movie i love
it john carpenter
i came here to chew
ass and kick bulk i'm all out of bass
and i'm all out of bubble ass
uh two you guys are always off about
these time stamps yeah oh she got scar
above her eye this must be after the the
next morning
yo you guys are good like what a catch
lookie there this is wow new rock stars
gets all their breakdowns going yeah
they'll be there just go guys send us
moments to talk about [ __ ]
dude eric boss is going to start live
streaming after today yeah
movement chat man tv electro with an arc
reactor in his chest he's god now
everything is iron man he's gone now
please
god don't [ __ ] say [ __ ] sake no
more storm shadow storm shadow from the
marvel comics uh gi joe series is uh
leaves a little moment of silence thank
you storm shadow i'm sorry about your
movie uh mustafa jav or jav or jav i
know
i loki hope andrew spider-man watches
tom spider-man save mj and whispers to
himself
show off everybody wants this app
to be such a weird thing for me
just hating him
dude i loved andrew's portrayal you know
when [ __ ] amazing spider-man came out
i felt like i was so alone
i was like
i like this movie
i i really enjoy i remembered really
enjoying that first amazing spider-man
and i was like yeah repeat some plot
beats from the first spider-man with sam
raymond but i actually quite liked him
and i actually thought andrew garfield
did a pretty good job in this room i
have no problem with the coolest fighter
i think he's i think he's better than me
that was my eternals oh here we go
before this turns into a fist fight
niece is back and niso levi all i know
is if mj dies in this movie the same way
gwen did i'm gonna cry all over for days
but still like that parallel wonder if
andrew will save her cosmic wonder that
would be a great sister channel parallel
wonder parallel um wonder yeah i mean
that would suck but i don't think
they're gonna kill off zendaya i mean
she just met up with timothy shalom oh
wait a minute
[Music]
any crazy theories from koi enjoy the
sketch by the way my craziest theory is
that at the end of this movie we have
not seen andrew and toby and that we get
a fourth spider-verse film so we ended a
cliffhanger that all of this leads up to
a sinister six film or a spider-verse
film that is uh that's my craziest
theory oh and and also a groot is in
this groot yeah oh dude well that's just
canon i thought i mean i confirmed it s
k z and g is she the last one uh nope no
we're nowhere near the last one do y'all
think andrew garfield is going to save
mj when she's falling nah
yes he'll help
yes
yes a thousand percent ramon and
elektra seems to have an iron man
reactor please [ __ ] hope
iron heart comes back and they keep
reminding us of iron man the whole time
savs reacts maybe i'm wiring uh maybe
i'm wrong sorry but when mj is falling i
think i saw something swinging but a
little bit blurry well yeah i mean spike
there's a spider-man spider-man's
falling but savage reacts go check out
sam's rack's youtube channel thank you
for such a generous super chat by the
way sabs nice when fellow reactors
support other reactors you know i don't
do that enough absolutely watch blind
wave
don't don't watch fellow quirky merc
channel blind women
i must know if this means anything to
you koi koi the rat tail boy also i
wonder if aunt may is going to die in
this movie yes she's going to die a
terrible death she's going to get
beheaded by the green couple all right
while quoting scripture
oh my god that was
nice my uh that was my high school uh i
ran for class president as koi koi the
rat tail boy cause i had a rat tail
until i was 16. i cut my wrist oh really
and i literally had this until i was 16
and it was such a big deal that i cut it
that 42 kids came to the cutting
ceremony and we filmed it and it was
this whole thing uh it was in the
yearbook it was like a whole section of
the yearbook with me cutting by rat tail
so uh someone i apparently know from my
childhood coy coy the rat tail boy
doesn't mean a lot to me and that is a
dark chapter because i had that
you've been stuck at one point i had a
bowl cut in a rat tail good yeah bring
that back that's a look
deliver us from evil
i think so okay 100 thanks for that gary
catlow i think someone just photoshopped
greg in the trailer i would love that
dude that would be great
too is that if koi could reimburse me 75
for a suit did i or did i not suggest we
do a live chat and say hey
and this is for the suit this is suit
funding and here we are
it's happening live hey rebel friend the
rebel friend says i feel like doc is
gonna be an ally after the bridge fight
peter uses the nanotech to fix the chip
to stop otto from going berserk [ __ ]
even in death uh iron man is saving the
day out you know what a suit of armor
around all circumstances
jsx oh yeah hey let's get an alex
garland mcu movie who's with me just
ralphie i i hope that one time john i
don't remember this we saw an animated
movie in school once about martin luther
king where like yes my friend martin
yeah where they like time traveled and
they like brought martin luther king to
the future but martin luther king didn't
get to live out the events that martin
luther king did and the world was in
hell
it's all [ __ ] up and like more racist
and and then they had to bring martin
luther king back to this time when he
died very dark bill intended they had to
deliver him back to the point where he
was already shot going they got to do
that with the end of the dock bring him
back to the time
last temptation of doc ock man
yeah it's just round just that last
temptation to crash to speed up this
whole process it's okay we're not on a
time crunch
just ralphy says love the vids guys
imagine if there are multiple versions
of each villain in this movie like
imagine if some die but then others come
back like a blue electro like 12
electrodes just all elections are
actually a sinister two much longer this
is an electro redemption it's all full
of electros and he gets his gap back by
the end of the movie's tooth gap drew
mckenzie i love the other spidey
villains but got even more hyped when i
saw
another sandman fan [ __ ] look like
the mummy frank gorilla now okay yeah
the face in the moment from our
childhood bring on more nostalgia hey
man brendan fraser going to join the mcu
i don't know
his two characters and his two
characters he's all over dc he's a robot
man and he's fire bug or whatever you've
just called him
serenity fireflies
and hell everyone loves popcorn flick
freaks i know that name 156 i think
because of universes converging doc's
testicles are morphing into something
that resembles stark attack
look at toby's dick
check his dick
yeah i mean it seems as though certainly
i mean i i appreciate to keep this quick
that each of the villains seems to get a
color related upgrade like the goblin
seems like he'll have something purple
not fast enough john
and doc look more green melanic joy i
think melancholy do you think
moreland moreland will
will appear in the after credit scene
will moreland appear in the after credit
scene uh moreland is a character from
the spider-verse story so the original
spider-verse deals with moreland which
are these animal totems so basically uh
j michael strozinski write wrote this
story where uh spider-man has all these
animal villains because he represents
animals he represents a totem of the
spider versus like you know you got
scorpion you got a lot of animal-based
feelings so uh moreland is part of a
race that hunts spider totem so he goes
through the spider verse hunting them
and that's actually how the spider-verse
multiverse concept was incorporated into
spider-man that being said we're leaning
into the mcu's version of the multiverse
which is much more cosmic much more
unilaterally impacting all of the mcu
characters so i don't think we'll get
moreland because this is a different
take on the spider-verse all together
that makes sense even as koi's falling
asleep he's killing the game
i woke up because i was like i'm useful
in it
all right
killing it coy jose kanez i hope i
did something with that who do you think
will die in this movie
either happy romney someone big no
i only had an apple this morning i've
had a bite of
someone's worried about being bloated
during his little interview
still
guys
brought to you by canon camera you can't
here i am i had an apple and then i
forgot to eat i forgot to eat today yeah
there's a lot of reasons for this and
may i think may might die for sure i
think ant-man i'm happy should both i
think tony stark's gonna die again i
think tony stark's gonna die again
somehow save the day yeah well that's
all they're doing lately with like we
should just pull back iron man from the
multiverse yeah
tom said this was the end of his era
right right coy i am tom's publicist uh
this is the end of the homecoming
trilogy tom said that this is the end of
that trilogy and it feels like a fitting
end but it also is very clear this is
the launch of something multiversal so
while it is ending a trilogy i do think
this is the beginning of uh a different
thing sure
uh quickly samuelson tuberon in the chat
hoping the movie will come out here uh
in time in the philippines sign that
petition uh so that hopefully maybe the
rest of the world can see the movie at
the same time philippines in japan
they're getting this movie way later
than everyone else
that's messed up
tide you know what the government should
do is deactivate twitter for anyone in
the philippines in japan
remove internet access get rid of it i
think that's the way the country should
operate all righty riptide thank you for
the moment of silence and uh jerry
phillips i love this little super chat
sticker i would enlarge it but it's
going to throw our place off but i love
this little doggy here and i'll go back
and see what he's saying later thank you
so much absolutely coming soon joseph
thiem
tom again said that this is the tip of
the iceberg other than matt murdock and
toby andrew showing up uh what other big
things do you think will happen
i
feel like
another big thing that will happen is
insert what koi is about to say
i think this will give us a it's a
college set film uh which a lot of
people aren't really talking about yet
is it yeah is there school involved it's
a college film
i don't think that's a spoiler
dude you know what [ __ ] channel we
are we don't give a [ __ ] if it's a
college
do you think like we're gonna be like
whoa
too big of a leakage so wait what you're
saying is what are you getting at this
is animal house meets endgame is what
you're saying it's project x with
spiderman
that's all i want i ruined it finally
little vlogs going back it's gonna be
great i've i'm willing to hear
everything but
get out where was the high school wrap
up this doesn't make sense we left so
far i i think we enjoy wait how do you
know it's a college film
we enter into a new phase i think of
spider-man lore here with this film i
think this is as much a launching pad as
it is a conclusion to the homecoming
trilogy oh wait i know wait koi how is
this a college film when
it takes place immediately after far
from home where he's still in high
school
and watch the movie in four weeks and
find out
am i gonna have to cut this out of the
video later
i don't think so but here we are i just
it's it starts
you go through
and you're slap
weird [ __ ] up and i need to move on to
milan's joy any sense to me
yeah it seems like it would be kind of
hard to do that unless there's a big
time jump or else the multiversal
madness just makes peter a little that's
how it's strange
that's how strange makes everyone forget
we're enrolling you in college
it would be way too busy and
sleep-deprived to remember this
spider-man will seem like a
hallucination all of it's a class in
your nightmare melancholy do you think
more oh uh
we're the same question
question i answered that a second ago i
don't think so but i gave a decent
reason five minutes ago hopefully it
suffices absolutely joel flores thank
you for the moment of silence so much
very generous of you we're not here to
sound disingenuous oh my god the carbon
outlaw what a generous ass super chat
that's the dominoes all right [ __ ] it
we're going to give our all here now
okay because i signed value yeah you
can't wait
for this movie i'll be in florida when
it comes out two questions
what are you most looking forward to in
the movie and
do you think wanda will make an
appearance in the movie possible in the
end credit scene of course i'm most
excited for the fact that toby and
andrew like toby mcgraw's my personal
i mean okay cory just met tom holland
they're all equal to me 100 equal in my
eyes
i do not have a favorite here that's the
correct they're all 100 percent the same
spider-man powerhouse level to me on
every way
however i am extremely excited at the
prospect of toby mcguire possibly
underscore possibly
to satisfy said sony people
and andrew garfield possibly showing up
in this movie
uh and
of course that's the thing i'm most
excited about like i think that final
battle is this gonna be [ __ ] banana
sandwich man yeah i i think uh i like
your wanda question i think that
post-credits scene if the doctor change
thing i posited is happening that will
possibly involve wanda i think if
there's ramifications coming from uh
this leading into the multiverse of
madison i think we'll tie pretty
directly so i love that idea if that's
one of the two scenes and um
most looking forward to i'm looking
forward to
seeing how sandman honestly seeing how
sandman and doc and the characters that
we grew up with incorporate into this
modern mcu like i'm fascinated by those
characters that literally shaped our
childhoods being part of this very
different universe you know something
that i really forgot to mention in our
actual trailer reaction was that
doc ock uh looked a little funky the
first time we saw him in the other
trailer looks great now right but yeah
those close-up shots i was like oh [ __ ]
that looks like real as [ __ ] yeah they
did the damn thing yeah man like that
shot where he says you're not you're not
peter
like that shot right there go back to
random pull that shot up there man show
them that shot look how good that looks
that looks [ __ ] great that's a really
good point that's stunning that looks
great
yeah absolutely everyone admire how
great this is look at it look at all of
this i mean if you really really pay
attention it looks a little fake
now that we were like
but in the moment it looked great very
impressive slap happy direction it's
okay it's okay he's still good he's
still good
weirdly enough today just based off this
trailer i'm actually excited at the
prospect of seeing
tom and peter and ned and mj actually
have to deal with this themselves kind
of and i hope that there is an aspect of
the three of them on this adventure
together and that's what i'm most
excited about it'll be very short-lived
uh i hope it isn't and i feel fear you
are right anthony toto
sony didn't show toby and andrew in the
trailer but
will they invite them to the world
premiere no way home without toby and
andrew interview that's why i thought
they'd be in the trailer just so they
could invite them to the premiere i mean
you how [ __ ] bananas would that be if
you saw toby and andrew at the premiere
holding hands
frolicking like like fast
i do think that you could have them at
the premiere without confirming they're
in it if you do it as like they're not
in the red carpet um like you could have
like a moment you could have the moment
uh without them in it at all and do a
post credit scene like i'm suggesting
but at the same time
i hope we don't find out that way if
they are like that'd be such a like when
when a bunch of people were like like
the variety leak for example i don't
want that to happen with this big of a
thing so i'd prefer that not be the one
yeah man brandon bella in the chat says
the end credits scene will go on for 30
minutes i heartily believe that i think
they shouldn't show up to the to the
premiere i think they should keep that a
secret as long as they can and then
start interviews like two weeks later
that would be so rough oh yeah armani in
the philippines
it's just [ __ ] ruined for every two
weeks have the premiere in the
philippines yes also people lamenting a
chance not to see greg uh shirtless just
now bummer armond derek easy specifies
in the live stream i'm a girl by the way
as she's
just showing her his body off and i'll
join her only fans she must be real
actually this text message i got this
morning this after this evening can i
read this text message to you guys corey
did you get a text like this
i don't like it sure maybe hi here are
you trent it's estrella we chatted on
tinder last time i went up to see my
relatives but we didn't meet for drinks
i'm back here just a bit if you want to
really meet up this time just a bit are
you busy and then john told me he got
that message and aaron got a message
like that yeah really mm-hmm i didn't i
got to dig it up was like i really know
when it's strong
when on a date and i didn't hear back
and you guys got the message i feel like
says hi koi thank you she's been trying
to get to you through us
now that you're tom holland's publicist
you're hard to get a hold of it clearly
arman deravakian
when doctor strange says i can't hold it
they are coming through it could be toby
mcguire spider-man and andrew garfield
spider-man i i feel like that's what
we're all expecting and i feel like what
he says here the dialogue is a little
too vague for him to just be like i need
to hold these two spider-men out i feel
like it's just
a punch of people and things from these
other universes or crashes what if it's
not villains and it's just a bunch of
spiderman it's a good thing when he
pulled over the she's just a whole bunch
of too many this is all the spiders
spider-man
what is spider-man spider-man war it's
peter parker it's it's been riley it's a
good thing he pulled over the spider-man
when they were in spider-man outfits oh
spider-man you really gotta catch them
just ketchup and day clothes are in
their underwear
robert sobriano this was john cena's
spider-man kicking lizard yeah cause you
can't you can't yeah because he's
invisible can you see me because he's
peacemaker because he's he's a
peacemaker crossover amalgam universe
confirmed michael keaton your recruits
and batman recruits and sinister six you
put him in the movie you gotta spiderman
jeremiah
did you guys think it's uh do you guys
think it's possible for one of the
spiderman to die i hope not not in this
one that would be a direct suck balls
that would be a drag i really hope none
of them die that i would hate that
thomas jefferson you know my thoughts on
certain spot i've been certain
spider-man yeah i mean i hope not we'll
see can anyone dies i hope it's tom
holland can anybody lean in and see it
the only way for you to live is to go to
the sony universe
i guess i have to it's gonna be great
thomas jackson can anybody read what's
on the chair continue like it says on
set on sets hey i love these little
stickers thank you so much thomas
jackson
jacob nice or nace uh if you watch
closely in the trailer where tom jumps
towards sandman in the big battle you'll
see lizard get punched by what ign's
youtube channel ign's youtube dislike on
their youtube channel he's like what up
boom andre abode thank you for the
moment for the milestone
uh proof spencer in television channel
professor spencer professor spencer
sorry
please pretty please with sugar on top
like an hour
oh yeah it's true
please
please with sugar on top cover the wheel
of time my absolute favorite high
fantasy series is being adapted to tv
hashtag dragon reborn wheel
c that's a big maybe man we'll see it's
a big baby it's a big maybe i appreciate
the support though john paul grima oh my
goodness moment of silence stream labs
coy and and uh brought this on yourself
what do the fists say does anybody else
what are the fists
i say thank you to the say you rock who
knows
get in there g
or they just fist they might just be
fists
fist bumps
all righty let's get these last stream
labs in here so that we can all go die
in the multiverse you know what greg
paid for his suit
everybody in the chat greg paid for the
suit
you guys and i drove to four different
stores looking for hispanics and suited
here's the story with the suit as this
loads i
i found a suit
and then it didn't fit as you can see in
the sketch then i went to four different
stores that whose website said they had
a suit all the stores
did not properly update their websites
they did not have any suit whatsoever so
that i went back to the first store and
i said [ __ ] it i gotta make something
new out of this sketch and i'll just
make a bit about me having to cut off
the head of this uh the spider-man thing
now world record show i was contacted
between each of these events and this is
when i still thought i'd be here and the
guilt grew
steadily in hindsight between each call
we're paying for that suit
yeah we saw we made the money back on
this live stream all right we did
we did it
okay we okay so we got hitman hudson i
feel like we're here all right that's
cool let's knock this out of the park
pseudo side looks like the nanotech from
the iron spiders transfers to doghawks
arms it's
okay to keep them closed like when he's
in the cage talking to peter maybe the
tech shuts down the chip that makes doc
evil in the rainy
that was once uh investment advice i got
was always invested in nanotech yeah i
love your content guys says
xmorningstarsx7 uh thank you lucifer i
follow their uh only fans oh yeah yeah
hell's yeah
yeah or i can actually subscribe to an
only fans every time i hear about people
subscribing to only fans they're always
like man what a [ __ ] rip-off
she didn't have sex with me afterwards i
thought it was like a strip club
and i love them
i uh pay for your porn people come on
sex work is working court sex workers i
don't watch porn so i don't pay for porn
but if you do i just wanted to save
money that's why i stopped hey you save
a lot of money uh james thousands a week
i'm sure somebody out there does uh tom
foley james leflay lafay i got this john
i could read a little bit faster tom
falling after mj one of the villains
stops him then when we get that heart
stopping moment andrew comes and catches
mj cut to toby swinging in to save tom
crow goes absolutely i love that i love
this not only does tom not successfully
save mj is that someone's another one
says
the breaker hd
hey rejects one question does electro
have his blue form from potasm too i
seen the new form but the frame where
spidey activates the magic thing on his
arm behind him it looks like electro is
at a power plant
and he has a blush tint am i reaching no
it seems that way to us too we noticed a
blue we think there's an evolution of
multiple characters and that very well
could be the second act or third
guys boogie we need a comment in the
live stream that will spark us
all right you in the middle you're
invited nick is i see you i see you nick
whack is yeah there we go that did it
have you seen the trailer from the
brazil sony twitter account they showed
lizard getting hit you know it's funny
after the first trailer it's who do you
think the sixth member the sinister six
is gonna be this one's like lizard punch
this is this one is
have you seen the trailer from the
brazil sony tour account they showed
those are getting hit by thin air during
that last shot with electro salmon and
lizard attacking tom holland and tubby
steps in kicks everyone's ass doctor
strange shows up they fight king the
conqueror yeah and then our shrimp shows
up with the eternals
i'm gonna judge you here in this fight
scene and yeah
and it's actually paul g mighty's rhino
that takes out the introduction you hear
the watcher and blade and nick fury's
voice off-camera all at once
multi-verse of voice is happening
simultaneously [ __ ]
what is it what is pootis and how do you
become a pootist guy let's not go down
that rabbit hole thank you pudus
alejandro hey guys coy you [ __ ] man
i'm so proud and happy for you along
with greg and john what did we do we
didn't get invited to host this thing no
they saw coy in our videos and said no
bring coy
never talked about spider-man before
yeah that's true i want all the credit
for any of koi's success
we deserve every anything coy gets in
life you have to circle back to here
right here and i want to be like you be
nothing without us chandra
nothing pictures of spiderman that's
what it does every time whenever i call
him he's like where the picture's better
what are you guys theory as to how
sandman and lizard fit into all this
well they get brought in by the
multiverse through the strangest spell i
really did like that mj said isn't this
kind of your fault because in the last
trailer stranger's like you done [ __ ]
everything up peter
be careful what you wish
especially if i'm giving it to you like
how are you just like pirates of the
caribbean choices yeah i am doctor
at a new thing though sorry uh the
they didn't um die in their respective
universes so why would they be fighting
to stay thanks uh we talked about that
earlier but i am very curious about the
doctor strange of it all because if they
didn't die which i had thought they had
that's a very good point and we will see
how that tracks lizard didn't die i
don't remember
i remember them on the roof or something
does he fall does he fall perhaps and
die like in his own form
that's right remember that sounds like
yeah because he's saying yeah he does
die because he saves andrew
after he kills redemption the the dad
and then i think he dies now he's like
i'm mad about my redemption yeah film it
lee hey hey everyone hey everyone do you
think there will be a possibility of
some sort of hinter cameo a mile showing
up for this final installment since he
was mentioned homecoming well if peter
is in college by this time then maybe
because maybe it's not quite a big
enough leap in age though and i do think
it's more likely that you see him in a
multiversal sense true you know what i
mean i don't know i think sonny might be
wanting to keep um
him in uh you know uh versus spider
nerd chronic has been cutting them
that's true chucky is [ __ ] great this
is money that we paid him that he's
giving back to us he's gonna ask for it
back
he's like can i get a bonus five dollars
for editing he didn't have an alien
chuck can you hold the can you launder
this five dollars and get it back to me
just clean it through streamlabs real
quick
congrats
hosting
cory
event and laundering this fiver it
looked like a blast and you deserve it
greg john do better
listen bud we're in here ever since he
left behind schmoed out he's been he's
gotten really really consistent
better chronic we did better by being
here still he's got 400 thousand views
guys he was like covered chucky i'm like
i don't want to cover chuck you better
cover chucky now
i hope chucky shows up in the multiverse
thank you nerd chronic we love you here
at the real reject studios man i do you
ben hoody
you guys are the best in the game your
coverage for this movie has been
absolutely phenomenal could not be more
excited for december the 17th the year
of our lord 2021 the wait is almost over
high pipe pipe thank you high pipe hope
hi
dude thank you for bringing us some hype
today i
d x dom
i i d x k don't i don't stable
care no as greg collapses and breaks
everything if you look at the one scene
with peter in the black suit and elektra
behind him he has something on his
chesticles and i think he's going to try
to
remake the moment electro quote died in
tasm 2 with the lightning to the chest
oh that's a new concept i like that idea
i don't know dom that's interesting and
we did talk about the electro chess
thing maybe maybe theory boogity huh
electrochesto boogie ha
slm
that's interesting i like that
fascinated by the thought process you
have here
it's true we haven't heard that before
it's a new idea way to give up
he's like
sorry yes
i don't know what that feedback was
sometimes i like to put words in orders
they've never this is just like a bunch
of adjectives that mean interesting
there's no actual feedback to that just
a lot of rambling stuff definitely
[Music]
hey so uh slm spider level market how
many people are in this [ __ ] stream
everyone left
there's negative 10 viewers in here now
we still have 2 800 people in here
almost 2 800.
almost 3 000 there are almost 3 000
people midnight
it's only going up
are we frozen ghost i mean i paused that
a long time ago so it wouldn't eat power
uh slm spider level marketing it seems
like the scenes with the black suit
are similar to the episode on
spectacular spider-man when he went
against the sinister six with the venom
suit
but but it's not what it will be here
it's not venom he's not gonna be a
symbiote dude i love what i'm hearing
what are you hearing
that me read these our videos doing okay
on youtube that's good dude that was the
whole reason almost this stream didn't
happen yeah the count 209
shouts out to my
my old guitar teacher terry the count
i'm so excited if
uh toby comes back as spider-man more
excited than when harrison foreign came
back as han solo i feel like this has to
be more satisfying than that of course
because [ __ ] han solo wasn't recast
in between that time you know what i
mean it's a different kind of like yeah
till later
it's because you know why they why it's
exciting that they're coming back
because they kept cancelling spider-man
yeah and starting over he's such a good
character and then they somehow wrote a
way to have that all work yeah i mean
and like they were always shouldn't be
good they always had the like for
whatever debate i feel like they got
caliber actors and good casting that
yeah it's just like if we could get
another great movie
you're right we should get taco bell
daniel rodriguez is getting us taco bell
we'll guess
will getting spider-man tickets be
harder than getting a ps5 for us man you
just get mama's geeky on top of it
she'll get us some spider-man tickets
that's right that's all right mama's
geeky tessa smith
good old youtube channel oh i didn't
know her name i like that sneaky name
look her up on the youtube and give her
a follow
and uh check out her comic book
recommendations for getting ready for
movies and trailers and stuff because
she's got good pulls are you going to be
uh showing down spectacular i got i got
a team in it oh who shazam how [ __ ] up
of course it's shazam i got shot their
last promo i'm not i'm not going to go
to showdown spectacular until
christian harloff finds a way to bring
back that dune audience
daniel rodriguez on the stage for real
yeah not compete just be on the stage
i'll sneak you in the back just bring
out a photo of heart laughter piss on it
open the back door you come out and be
leave so yes coy will be at the
spectacular
come let him pee on you and leave it's a
whole thing eclipse
eclipse gts1
the last fan question at the event by
cosplayer taya asked what was the uh
what was tom's favorite characteristic
as spider-man and he mentioned being
peter parker do you guys agree or
disagree i so agree uh taya also i was
hanging out with at new york comic-con
didn't realize that was the same taya in
the crowd so taya i'm sorry um that's a
lot of ties i need a lot of ties in the
game um i do think that was the best
possible answer so much so and this is a
behind the scenes moment uh tom was
leaving for the day and i was gonna stay
and do another round of trailers out of
just like wanting to be in that space
and uh i waited for them to wrap up all
of their like signing and stuff to
literally tell tom hey man i've
interviewed a lot of people that play
characters that are comic book
characters but that response was the
most authentic i think i've heard
someone embody a character so i i
personally like think that was one of
the best uh questions and that was one
of the reasons i wanted to rap after i
was like this is a beautiful thing and
then i asked my silly question about
dance battles but yes that was one of
the best questions that is delovely i
love that and i'm looking forward to a
peter parker-centric film this time
around i would like that
ramon fritz according to google over 350
million views now the most viewed
trailer in the first 24
hours yeah it's kind of [ __ ] insane
views man yeah oh yeah same views
absolutely possible and a really good
like to dislike ratio brandon gurney i'm
like our reaction gurney from dune over
here
they removed the gurney button let me
tell you guys about this [ __ ] you
the thing about it's been on about it
all night for all week we are at zero
zero
420 000 views in real time yep and 253
aspects man that's almost like 1 100th
of a percent really affected i just want
to know yeah what did you want people
appreciating the fact that you guys
messed it up
if we [ __ ] something up here you go
don't ask those people
here you go i really think you got to
email them directly call him like that
great super fan chat brandon gurney so
okay so i've had this through for a
while and i'm gonna read this so
sincerely now humor me guys here okay
you know how marvel is with their jokes
right i think at the end of the film if
and slash when gabi gets sent back to
his universe it'll be right before he
gets impaled giving reason to this
reaction of oh
that's actually kind of fun
like oh the bubble we're going to bring
up the sam
like he gets transported back if they
can retroactively make that very cheesy
joke work i love that yeah he literally
pops back into his body like oh like
that's hilarious
i like that brand that's that's clever i
would love to see a montage of them all
going back to the respective universes
and just dying
morty lord draven dredson crazy to your
idea guys crazy the trailer actually
does show andrew garfield
when holland jumps to save her he's
wearing the mask next shot no mask and
andrew's hair
oh this brother's definitely definitely
going to be some trailer manipulation
this trailer is filled with like oh [ __ ]
they totally cgi'd out a bunch of stuff
that's the benefit they deep faked
andrew what was all so fascinating to me
is that this came out on marvel's page
before the sony page
that new deal is fascinating at least in
our
notification bells am i on marvel's page
that'd be dope
like this guy only thinks about himself
always just selfish am i on marbles am i
on marvel's page right now i'm on the
real rejects page do we get lord draven
dressmen here i'll have you know
that
kevin feige actually once said something
about me yeah
no
god no
that's excited for him
don't worry that's the end of the bit
all right
lord dresden raymond
i love that theory man
um yes nolan lynch looks like doc ock
has some star tech upgrades and then
uh red
maybe more proof he might be working
with peter in the gang well he absorbs
it during the fight and i think that's
what brings it back to reality and goes
you're not
you're not you're not peter mom's
spaghetti you have too much energy my
peter is sleepy there goes gravity
there's a real mom's spaghetti
restaurant we don't kill aunt in this
universe oh they get married and oop we
should sleep alvin what's up koi hey koi
great job at regal hey the pictures i am
the guy dressed as og wrestler
spider-man from spider-man 1. boom saw
is red oh he's raised
so this guy was leaving and wanted to
take a picture and everyone was like i
had a security detail escorting me out
like they were they were trying to get
you had a security detail
oh it's crazy did you sick them on
anyone uh i didn't need to but i thought
how cool that would be you should don't
like get this guy to my face i don't
want to like
get the man um but uh he had such a cool
costume that was talking to him he's
like you might have got a picture but i
was already being escorted up the stairs
like to leave so i took a picture like
like he was on the ground and i was
leaning over like above what
so it's like a super it's funny yeah so
uh if you could tag me in that i would
love to see that photo why why why
wouldn't they let you just hang out with
the fans because i was the i was gonna
be running the next thing so we had to
clear the space like if i just stayed
yeah i stayed for do more trailer things
i stayed and like helped with the next
so if i like kept people in the space so
they had to have security mainly for my
own zeal [ __ ] man yeah it was cool
thank you man i i want to see that photo
his name is back gear don't forget it
back here no i know that's a different
guy back here it is possible that
electra after he died an amazing
spider-man and he got back to normal but
he still manifests the ability of
electricity as danae that he got an
upgrade from doc octavius that would be
in
in conjunction with dr octavia i could
see a version here where doc och and
elektra are getting along with each
other doc helps them out and then bam
yeah they have a separation it's a trail
like electricity yeah electricity
electro betrays like electric like how
big electricity betrays you
sometimes it's positive sometimes it's
negative it's zaps yeah who knows what's
gonna happen just electricity portrayed
us brought to you by canon cameras
thank you backyard i've been this tired
in so long oh hey oh what a great way to
end this flev the [ __ ] doran lev the
[ __ ] dorian just woke up and watched her
trailer so hyped better than any cup of
coffee great skit by the way well we
whipped that sketch out of our ass i
referenced batman and robin in that
opening pulled the exact sound effects
from that movie and i feel like nobody
really recognized it that was true
batman robin is what we were making fun
comment bomb the video understanding the
reference now
guys
are we are we caught up i'm making sure
we caught up we've got two mothers
we did it right how do we end this
i don't know how to close these ones
oh these are new
okay og wrestler we got that we got flev
doran okay so we got a couple a couple
stragglers we are no more with the
stream labs and i'm sorry if we might
miss you yeah but i'm falling asleep and
i gotta drive all right coy's got an
hour drive home frizzy even though this
was his idea to do the live stream you
know what we paid for your spiders you
wouldn't [ __ ] listen to me
oh very wise all jokes aside i've been
having a great time quick i i i admit
i've been having a better time than i
thought
all right
as much as i've been not looking forward
to having to prep these videos for the
next two hours for the morning i am also
very uh i i've been having a really good
time
audio reaction yeah this has been fun
all right so quick medley of all the
stragglers in the super stickers ryan
shaw thank you so much for that big
smiley
uh cosmic wonder i'm sorry we made you
cry [ __ ] i know you make more
money than that
michael welton
whoa michael
is that like a is that like a little guy
turning into a gundam or something damn
that's amazing what a kind not even a oh
my god just through a sticker that is so
generous hey look it's your spider suit
you give me crap about it look at that i
can blow these up i can blow these up
now because all right
spiders should you give me crap
thank you so much michael welty that is
a very cool sticker uh wembley frog
gaming one keeping it one hundred prong
game thank you landon
hell yeah fox dog thing oh man my
batteries are dead i can't even smoke my
vape now ace wow and then resign with
which you dropped it on your own things
are falling apart here at the real
rejects ace gunner 49 able hey you hey
you right back at you so much later
daniel parks this is a city skyline go
back to the beginning of this stream i
said we have to end by 10 30. it is now
11 58 pm that is a beautiful skyline
daniel parks i also said i also notice
we tend to end later than when i say but
we have to stick to the end time and we
have not succeeded anywhere near such a
long stream daniel parks since the
skyline thank you so much brian thank
you for the poop for the patrick stewart
quinn remembers
you you're so nice i really appreciate
with the crazy hypno eyes i really
appreciate it thank you feeling dizzy
that's all of us right now this one's
all about that we can be like on this i
have a channel where you guys show your
support like this is [ __ ] incredible
anthony ryan done
thank you so much
if anybody else sends stickers we'll
catch them later but really appreciate
y'all this live stream will not have
solid playback value no brian here's a
dollar that covers the cost of the suits
right yeah
shut up it's that super 83
it was eighty dollars and the guy knew
it didn't fit so he gave me a twenty
percent discount that's kind yeah
shout out to that i tried it on and he's
like dude this ain't gonna fit he's like
i'll give you a 20 discount
i have no value for this like make that
sale
[Laughter]
[Music]
just wanted to say love you guys keep up
the great work i love you actually do
things to you cinematic goodness out of
curiosity what are your guys ex what are
you guys expecting from the villains
what do you want from them what half of
them to be underrated
oh it's gonna be 240 of awesome do you
think they'll get any development or
simply uh be obstacles for peter love
your cat
by the way been a big fan of you guys
since 2014. thank you so much thank you
so much well i think that uh what are we
expecting from the villains i think um
the villains uh
i think doc ock's really gonna be
handled well green goblin i feel like
will be more sinister than before
um
i'm really i am a little bit concerned
though in the electro and um i know i
feel like they're bringing a lot of
attention lecture was like one of the
first things announced with this movie
forever ago i think electro and sandman
might be kind of like sandman and
hydroman were where they team up and are
kind of a force of literal nature so in
the comics sometimes they teamed up and
then they actually became this mud demon
and i'm wondering if they utilize that
as like electric and com like uh uh
impact and electricity so it's kind of
like an extra attack on them so i i'm
wondering if they become a force of
again i use force of nature as an
expression but i mean literally
something like that attacking
simultaneously yeah did you know elect
eternals got like a 48 percent on
ronaldo you know i i did that we
definitely don't have time for that
imoto spidey with the magic over his
wrist is him sending them to the magic
prison and lizard was in the prison at
the end of tasm to set up the sinister
six movie
was that a prison or was that just an oz
escort based it's an oscar basement
prison like i got the next movie in my
basement i'm gonna go figure this out
the basement
josh johnston
lizard is getting punched by
ang lee's
in this crazy ass spiderman fan event
with tom hall in there
there for hours and now he's just
[ __ ] stuck on this list
you will never stop talking about this
trailer
check out my social medias i've got
emails from sony that i haven't even
opened i'm just like we're going to do
this we're going to do this
josh johnston drags me up i love this
this night of his life and he's just
trapped in this red just i wouldn't be
here i wouldn't have time look at me now
look at me now josh johnston this took
me on a ride the first time i read it uh
lizard is getting punched by angley's
hulk and the six sinister six villain is
nick nolte
i want that movie josh bring it josh you
know
that's good no that's good i would say
that okay yeah i think i fell asleep the
first time i watched it in the theaters
i think i liked that
but i liked it big fan of it for sure it
was easy to sleep too
nice
you know i was inoffensive and easy to
sleep too it gave me a lot of rest which
i don't get i do live streams till
midnight hey quinn black suited
spider-man gets doctor strange to cast a
spell power up on his arm just like in
what if uh with the evil doctor strange
keep the awesome content coming i need
to read this again i'm so sorry
this is the last one
maybe yes yes it is it is it is we're
not refreshing right now
because this is 11 54 when that battery
we said we said it we said we will send
direct messages via email to those who
spider-man gets doctor strange to cast a
spell power up on his arm just like in
what if with the evil doctor strange
keep oh i get what he's saying yeah
yep i like that thank you
i'm glad i understood that
it's good i like it dude eric boss just
finished his breakdown script
oh he's here to screenshot it and omni
media is in the chat and the jedi bro
one of our patrons i can't on a stack
you know what we've dissected this
trailer right now eric
so much the audience has helped us out
so much frame by frame here it's
literally taking us to moments and we've
dissected it so much i'm wondering when
watching yours
your breakdown
if
if we're like oh [ __ ] they pointed out
so
boss pointed out so much that we did not
even after two and a half hours talking
about this goddamn trailer we did not
hey this stream's almost long as a movie
i know right for that last super sticker
that was very uh lovely of you g for
sending that
really damn boss just finished his
script he hasn't even filmed that [ __ ]
that dude crazy good for you man that's
a good response got a night ahead of him
hey hey don't talk kindly to your
enemies i mean
my nemesis that i've been sworn against
eric voss good job mvp of the stream
sardon or mr janjaro that's the question
don't say coy or greg or john say just
coy or mr jandro i'm not in the mood for
john's here
i'm not in the mood for my uh for people
not to vote for me and and then and not
take the joke personally
that's that's very that's real let's
make them all coy options that's and
then i still lose
yeah everyone just writes
everyone write greg in the chat just
type it in because all engagement is
good engagement just just just
chatbot greg's name i think i think we
did it man i think we did it right we
did it we still got to edit a couple of
other things
me too
so is john
eric doesn't want to fight you i don't
want to fight you
you have to eric your next live stream
eric be here next time no eric you've
been pitted against me unbeknownst to
myself let's let it be known let it be
known right here eric doesn't want to
fight coy a lot of people don't know
about eric because he's secretly like
six foot eight in real life oh really
yeah it's like a [ __ ] basketball
i'm wide though but i don't think it'll
help if you got the reach on me i'm
scrappy i'm irish i don't know why we're
physically fighting i thought we were
gonna
turn this into a pants eric do you have
any irish in you or are you a pure
german boy
i feel like vos is quite a german as is
quite a german surname i'm the whitest
i've ever been
he's trying to get me to fight others
yeah
i'm screenshotting
let's see which
yes all people are spamming greg in the
chat
people are spamming greg from the chat
but guys let's face it john is the one
who actually
realized real life
everything we've been doing is just all
happened with quite honestly our last
hour we've been intelligent john is john
is literally safe thanks to reggie sen
for writing my name mvp reggie is the
only one that knows what's up john is
really he really is the one who's this
is the only possibility
guy in the chair and eric voss
this part's fun
this part's fun this part's fun all
right i can't wait to see eric voss's uh
stream uh breakdown yeah yeah
i'm gonna watch that it's great i hope
it's gonna be 24 minutes long
final poll of the day
coy is leading uh koi and koi and koi
i'm curious by also koi versus still coy
is it a phrasing issue did one of them
betray someone was it more of an
existential quandary of like am i
remaining or is it an addendum to me
because i feel like all sukhoi is more
of a ben reilly where still coy is more
of like a peter b parker because he's
like stuck being spider-man felicia
hardy alongside spider-man mr gender
seems like parker industry spider-man
where he's like a little bit too adult
he's got an iron man problem he's an
international man it doesn't really suit
the character so coy to me seems like
the more linear streamline tom holland
has peter parker so i'm glad he's
winning you know coy you parked about
seven minute walk away uh i think you
should
just go stop talking so much
get out of here so we can say
guys listen this stream has been a blast
i'm so happy to even the uh fellow
colleagues and other people that joined
in people such as the mr voss the mr
wonder cosmic no heavy spoilers you jerk
you must be going on that trip finally
oh and um
you know the freaking uh there was
another omni media was in here at one
point my mom um stephanie gendro the
hottest woman in the world thank you sir
uh jedi bro what's up man for the uh
thank you for the thumbs up
and uh yeah i mean all you guys who've
been in here with us guenter 830 oh my
god
831 sent us a 50 sticker thank you for
that that's really kind to you and for
the future i'm always going to pull up
the stickers here if i
yeah
can
so beautiful look at that little lemon
lemonade
those look like uh adventure time
characters
about the different
existential quandaries about the use of
phrases and how it might separate the
spiderman
cory you seven minute walk i'm sorry 45
minute drive
um it's tomorrow this has been it's
virtually tomorrow
koi plus craig eagle's john gymsky says
the flex check is very true without him
is it i don't know about that
okay lizard was in the post-credits
scene of the amazing spider-man thank
you supreme talk oh that does help i
appreciate that guys listen um thank you
to everyone for being here and then um
you know like we don't do live streams
often but whenever we get like super
chats like this it still blows my
[ __ ] mind away i'm not gonna lie like
thank you thank three almost 3 000 of
you for still being here
thank you for the 4 000 plus likes
that's amazing and thank you all for
your time and thank you everyone who
watched our video we're like we're not
in the [ __ ] eric vos numbers because
we're we don't know how to become an
eternal
but
we're at like you know they probably
have four times this amount of views by
now
you're cross-referencing are you
enjoying your own numbers
don't compare yourself yeah being a
[ __ ]
being a bit of a [ __ ] here are you
inviting anguish upon yourself are you
doing a thing you're being a [ __ ] all
right guys 428 000 views is that this is
boggles my mind and then 259 dislikes is
just you know i was like that was the
question i thought the dislike i was
asking whether you're comparing your
[ __ ] to your own [ __ ] why are you with
the dislike why you reading it i just
don't know man it just [ __ ] bothers
me you know guys this has been a blast
we're all slap happy thank you for
joining us we will catch you the next
time some live streamable event happens
these are fun and sporadic
uh have a good night uh sound off guys
so much hey guys another round of
applause for koi zhandro koi thank you
man the people that were at the event
tonight like getting a cheer uh as i
came out before like people were like it
was crazy to be me at a thing so i was
honored dude be you at everything me and
everything it was it was just really rad
to be there on my own so thank you guys
i appreciate the support like so much
all right we will catch you so you're
never going to actually pay me back for
that suit
and blackout
that's the end bye stephanie bye thank
you guys so much all the love all